so the economy continues to fall apart
housing prices in certain areas have
dropped like 20 percent many people are
predicting recession we are seeing mass
layoffs in the housing market and crypto
but crypto's kind of obvious we know
they're getting laid off because they're
getting just obliterated but uh joe
biden says it's tremendous rebound or
i'm sorry it was the hill they said
despite the rebound people are still
feeling the heat or whatever and it's
like dude it's massive inflation there's
talk of i don't know if they did this
today the fed was going to increase uh
rates by what like 0.75 or something
like that by 75
what is the number almost almost one
percent or something like that i mean
it's up to like 6.2 right now something
like it's gonna go up it's gonna get
it's gonna get crazy out there and so
now um you know i could not resist this
headline i've been hurt all day because
you guys know i didn't i didn't work
today or yesterday morning but i really
want to do the show that's why i was
resting and so i just said luke what's
in the news and luke was like oh that
leftist congressman said there's going
to be a civil war if the republicans win
the midterm and i was like that's our
headline that's exactly what tim poole
wants and uh no but i thought it was a
good kickoff because we've got protests
in front of kavanaugh's house we've got
the migrant caravan 7000 plus heading
towards the border this is one of the
biggest yet we've got elon musk
intervening sort of when libs of tick
tock is getting death threats and i
guess now twitter actually started
banning these accounts but all of these
things obviously play into this this
massive divide and i think when you see
a
congressman member of the squad say that
the right has been radicalized if they
win they're going to start you know
taking more uh power in federal
government and then he mentions you know
people who want a civil war and that's
what's at stake so we're going to talk
all about that stuff we'll talk about
what's going on in the border especially
with these fine young gentlemen who are
down there we got drew hernandez
good to see you guys i'm enjoying the
great reset i think it's amazing i think
joe biden is doing a great job and uh
you know what i think this build back
better agenda is just the perfect thing
for our country just want to get that
out of the way so uh
it's it's looking good guys we also got
jorge ventura hey it's good to be here
and uh like drew said uh great reset's
going great i'm excited to uh live in z
in z pods and eats bugs hear that media
matters we're a good show we are great
we just want to get that out of the way
yeah yeah we got luke
i hope media matters stops watching
luke's
[Applause]
people will forget your words people
will forget your accomplishments but
people will never forget that you voted
for biden yes if you like that message
it's on my t-shirt you could get it on
the best political shirts dot com and
support me thank you so much for having
me screw that look you need a t-shirt
that says
[Laughter]
how do we follow that yeah
i need people to speak like very slowly
when they speak spanish to me because i
you know i speak it better than i
understand it but that's how i am with
english too wait
a
minute
uh excuse
[Laughter]
so me racist remarks are going to be
thrown at the guests on this show
a lot of racism
my name is uh sheamus coughlin i have a
youtube channel called freedom tunes we
upload animated cartoons every single
week sometimes twice a week we got some
bangers coming out over the next two
weeks um
and i've also got a website i just
launched freedomtunes.com you guys go
over there five bucks a month you are
going to get extra content an extra
cartoon every week you're also going to
be supporting independent content so we
will not be as reliant on big tech and
can also make jokes that uh won't
necessarily fly on youtube oh nice
freedom cannot believe that i told this
nice lady that i met today to tune in to
the show this evening and luke kicks it
off i'm great i hope it gets better from
here nice to see you again guys we also
we've got a couple uh people chilling we
got richie mcginnis and taylor silverman
hanging out in the back of the shirt
yeah that's a good shirt i like
is that one of your shoots and shirts
yes it is oh it's john mcafee right yeah
yeah
john mcafee
yeah
all right everybody before we get
started we have a great sponsor we have
biotrust ageless multi-collagen go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and pick up
your order you can get it for 51 off i'm
literally drinking it right here in my
beverage because as you know my back is
all messed up and so i'm like trying to
do everything possible i think i'll be
fine by tomorrow i took some magnesium i
took some of this stuff head over to
stronger bones and life.com and you can
get a 60-day money-back guarantee on
your ageless multi-collagen this is
stuff you need for your joint hair skin
and nails it makes your bones stronger
and makes your your life better five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources hydrolyzed collagen
peptides meaning better and faster
digestibility to support maximum
benefits and for every order today they
will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid hungry.org to
date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids please help
biotrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners nearly no
odor or taste unlike bone broth and
other collagen supplements no clumping i
can attest to that no clumping right
here free shipping with every order free
vip live health and fitness coaching
from biotrust team of expert nutrition
and health coaches for life with every
order in their free e-report the 14
foods for amazing skin with every order
again
strongerbonesandlife.com but don't
forget to head over to timcast.com
become a member to support our work
directly we have a members only show
coming up at 11 p.m tonight i can only
imagine with the amount of people we
have in this room it'll be particularly
rowdy and fun so
you want to check that one out because
i'm sure it'll be as i mentioned rowdy
but you're also supporting our
journalists we have a bunch of great
reporters we're hiring more we just had
another reporter today so i'm really
excited for all of this and our
infrastructure we're working on some
infrastructure deals in the background
because we want to get away from these
big tech silicon valley censorship
machines that's why we use rumble
infrastructure on the back end for our
website and for our video player we got
more coming so again smash that like
button subscribe to this channel share
the show with your friends let's jump
into the first story i just want to
mention the reason tim is has had a pain
in his back is because luke has moon
trousers and syndrome by proxy and he's
been slowly poisoning him he's been
literally stabbing me in the background
really funny though i thought you're
gonna say because luke has a pain in his
back that's awesome that would have been
more clever pain in the behind would
have been something you know an adult
would say all right here's an adult are
you going to lecture all right no more
laughing now we're going to get
depressed here's the story
black pills yeah squad rep bowman
predicts civil war if gop takes control
in midterms i do think that headline is
a little strong yeah what he actually
said was
he went on to warn that republicans
gaining control of the house and or
senate would embolden dangerous and
violent extremists to take further
control quote it would also embolden
republicans and the far right and white
nationalists across the country to begin
to believe that it is their time to not
just take power in the house but the
senate the white house and the state
houses across the country we've got to
understand that this is a group that has
been radicalized by the great
replacement myth and many other things
and have been pushing for violence and
pushing for even civil war so that is
what's at stake right now in terms of
this election he warned i'd like to
point out
that it's a ridiculous statement yeah
republicans just did a deal on gun
control you you don't you don't see
republicans coming out and being like
they're all could you imagine mitch
mcconnell being like i want a machine
gun in the hand of every child like it
just there's nowhere they're nowhere
close to anything like that so to come
out and say they're radicalized but the
funny thing is
what about winning an election makes him
think they will then move for civil war
like exactly people revolt when they're
losing right political system winning in
the political system emboldens a person
to keep trying to pursue more victories
within the political system you know i
don't know about you guys but i'm really
excited about the republicans getting
into power and then sitting on their
hands and doing absolutely nothing
that's wrong you are wrong luke they're
not going to do nothing they're going to
capitulate to the democrats and take
away our rights
no but you are right
they're trying everything they're
throwing everything at the wall and
hoping that it sticks from the roe v
wade uh to obviously this j6 they're
trying everything they can to just throw
it out there to radicalize their base
and uh i don't know i feel like the j6
stuff is not gonna stick with them
because i think a lot of people are
watching this stuff and it doesn't add
up i mean they they have this show trial
don't they have like an an abc uh
producer putting the trial together it's
impossible to watch it it's ridiculous
and people are watching this like is
this really a threat like is this really
the threat is this really is it going to
be climate change is it going to be roe
v wade what is it going to be a police
killing a bunch of black people like
they try everything and i just hope a
lot of people are waking up to like they
just want to manipulate you in radicals
you see jake paul
jake paul came out and was like if you
don't see why voting for biden was the
problem you're the american problem and
he's not like a right winger and you
know uh you know bowman's actually you
know whatever whatever you think of him
he's actually he's he's a lot smarter
than this and he knows that he's
actually stoking division when he goes
this lane he calls himself a progressive
so he understands the struggles of the
working class he should just be honest
and say hey if the establishment
democrats could you know continue on the
way they are we're losing the
working-class vote people can't have you
know even afford gas groceries and
bowman knows that he's he's a
progressive but he's he's kind of
aligned himself with the establishment
ever since he got into office like the
rest of the the squad
who voted for the 40 billion for ukraine
yeah and so i want to make a point
bouncing off that i think you're
absolutely correct there and one thing i
would add is it's interesting that
someone who's part of the squad which
has very strong leanings if not overt
support for marxist theory would say
that there's going to be a revolt in
this country because the wrong political
faction is winning and not because i
don't know gas is gonna reach eight
dollars a gallon because your average
person is struggling to buy food because
people are incapable of caring for their
own family with a single wage that's the
funny thing but he knows that the thing
is he's smart enough to aoc she knows
that but they decide not to talk about
those issues they have now aligned
themselves with the establishment and i
mean i think the funniest thing about
the uh the squad is they champion
themselves like oh we're the outsider
we're going to go in and we're going to
fight pelosi in the in the staffs
malefic and they just literally align
with them every single way yep i think
they might start leaning into the civil
war narrative because the real issue is
when people can't eat when they can't
drive when they can't work that's when
you start seeing the breakdown i forgot
what it's called but there's like an
equation or whatever that when the cost
of uh i think we talked about it before
yeah we did when the cost of goods
reaches a certain point to the cost to
the value of labor then it just the
system breaks what's the what's the
quote we're only three meals away from a
revolution yeah i forgot who said that
uh but someone will correct me in the
comments that was uh that was just we
that was uh it was um the jurassic
drastic world dominion that's who said
it yes exactly yes that's when we saw
the movie together and that's why it
just came to my mind right now didn't
invite me but we didn't three meals away
from a revolution
exactly and historically we have to we
have to understand whenever there's
civil unrest whenever there's a larger
conflict whether internal or external it
usually is fostered because of economic
instability and chaos this economic
instability is being spurred on by
deliberate decisions by the biden
administration that is literally
shooting this economy in the foot and
this is going to prelude a larger
conflict that's going to unfold in some
kind of way because history dictates
that this is going to happen because it
always happens this way come on man come
on man i totally agree well you agree
with me yeah i know every now and again
the man makes a good point and
you're completely correct i would go a
little bit further too i think there's
something very unique about the present
economic crisis we're facing which is
that people don't really have any
ability to gauge what normal prices are
because during the pandemic we actually
saw a bit of deflation within key
industries so for example the cost of a
gallon of gasoline where i was living
was like a dollar 45 cents so if we had
a relatively normal cost of gasoline
back in 2020 and it was something around
like 253 dollars and now it was up to
five dollars that would certainly be a
problem but when people are used to gas
being significantly less expensive than
the average and then it shoots up over
five dollars you're going to see massive
economic consequences that which you
wouldn't otherwise see well it's like
it's it's like an inverse big ask right
so here's here this is the trump method
right i think he writes about this in
the art of the deal i haven't read it
but the idea is ask for like twice of
what you want so i'd be like drew give
me a hundred dollars for this you know
drink and then when you're like 100
bucks that's crazy i'll say okay 50 and
you're like ah 50. that's half even
though 50s that you know you ask for way
more than you want this is an inversion
of that where people get used to a
really i'll put it this way
if you were if you were in a place at a
dollar fifty for gas
and it jumps to five bucks you're
looking at a massive increase
if it was already four bucks for like a
year you'd be angry and used to it you'd
be desensitized so this is a much much
bigger shock to people and you'd be
upset by it anyone's going to be upset
by price increases especially if their
wages are not rising at an equivalent
rate but
it's also the fact that people have sort
of lost the ability
to make calculations about what things
should ordinarily cost because nothing's
really been at a normal price for about
two years or so we've got a lot of news
in the economy but let's stick to the
civil war topic because even yahoo news
released an article just moments ago and
it's titled the supreme court could
foster a new kind of civil war so this
is conversation that's being normalized
i was warning about this for you know a
couple years now it's called the divide
and conquer agenda and i think it's
important to understand right now
because from my perspective there's a
bunch of ruling elites manipulating the
left and the right to fight each other
on cultural issues on issues that i
would even regard as petty in some
instances while we are getting screwed
and literally robbed of our wealth and
money and potential to have any kind of
legitimate future for our children so so
i i think you know this term
civil war you've been talking about it
forever tim i i i think is is something
that we should discuss further because
i think there's a big potential for this
well i think
we're in a new kind of civil war already
i've certainly talked about it when you
when you see the left go around
destroying buildings in 2020
529 never forget the leftist
insurrection at the white house where
they tried tearing down the fences they
tore down the barricade set fire to a
guard post and they tried to raise saint
john's church the famous president's
church and 150 officers get injured in
these protests that was an insurrection
the president was forced into a bunker
and they laughed at him for it how many
federal agents and officers of the law
were injured there 150. and tim
here's my point real quick sorry it's
just that where is the where is the the
hearings where the arrests where's the
uh
where's any republican to come out and
be like look what happened here yeah so
when the federal government and law
enforcement is only going after one
group of people
and the other faction is doing
substantial more substantially more
damage
yeah okay look the gov it's some people
say anarcho-tyranny and i'm like
anarcho-tyranny is like criminals get
away with it but law-abiding citizens
get arrested this is something different
this is antifa and far leftists go
around smashing and destroying and then
the media and the government look away
and then you get a handful of like
what are this patriot front group that
no one believes is real anyway and no
one cares about gets arrested for simply
going into a city they get surrounded
they get a conspiracy charge i mean look
everybody thinks they're feds anyway so
i kind of thought it was funny but if
you're people in a truck and they
surround you and arrest you just for
that i mean you didn't do anything we're
already at a point where two billion
dollars in insurance damage and it was
probably more than that buildings
destroyed burned down all across this
country and nothing 30 30 or so deaths
related to the to this riding and
nothing i don't care look arrest patriot
friend if they're doing something wrong
right but what about literally the other
factions that are doing substantially
worse nothing is getting done well we
definitely are
uh are in a political psychological
information war that you're seeing
unfold through education through the
mainstream media through movies through
hollywood through music through crt
through all of these agendas and
teachings that come through all these
channels and i think i think the bigger
picture
here is it's not necessarily left versus
right it's this global agenda from the
top down and i think the yuna party is
nothing new but i think a lot of people
view it this way where it's like it's
left versus right in the united states i
think that's the way they want us to
view it they want us into a civil war
they want us attacking each other so it
gives this global elite an excuse for
full government overreach and the the
the craziest part about this entire
thing is
people that believe they're on the right
side right which we would say like
people on the left or whatever right
people that think the useful idiots that
are on the ground like tim is talking
about the antifa people the blm people
these far leftists these marxist
professors and universities and you name
it right these people think they're on
the right side because they have the
power in all these institutions
especially big tech that's another one
to name they think they're on the right
side but you're literally being used
just to push an agenda forward so that
the bigger powers at b can come in and
just have an excuse to take over
everything and anyone that's not in line
at that point does it matter whether
you're on the left or the right if
you're not in line with the power
structure or the agenda you're gone
absolutely one of the biggest hurdles to
the expansion of authoritarianism in
this country is the constitution what's
the easiest and fastest way to get rid
of a constitution
emergencies civil war yeah a civil war
one side comes out on top and then you
say
that's just gone that's gone right so uh
we with abraham lincoln right the
suspension of habeas corpus i think they
they threatened to arrest the assembly
in maryland i think they arrested and
killed people by the state for for just
simply disagreeing with the centralized
government at that time well it's
interesting you were mentioning the fact
that people have really been
propagandized to accept a lot of these
left-wing ideas but even so going back
to tim's comments about
may 29th and the way that's treated as
compared to january 6th for as
propagandized as public has been
according to polling data something like
two-thirds of people would like to see
an investigation into the 2020 riots
whereas less than half of american
citizens polled want an investigation
into january 6th so even though it would
be tremendously politically popular for
the republicans to look into the 2020
riots
i'm not going to hold my breath
what's interesting about the um the 20
20 riots and being there covered on the
ground the majority of the businesses
that were burned down were black and
brown owned immigrant owned i was
actually i was an intern for the daily
call but my first night on the ground
was actually 5 29 and i've you know i've
never seen anything like that when they
were attacking secret service now that
night i don't know if you guys remember
but i um i broke the story of he was
with fox news at the time lelian vitter
he was assaulted by those black lives
matter supporters now could you imagine
if it was cnn jim acosta then it was the
other way around i mean we would they
would never let us forget about it i
guarantee you people don't even remember
that leland got got assaulted because he
works for fox news but if it was jim
acosta oh man we would we wouldn't hear
the end of it i'll take it a step
further blm attacked cnn's headquarters
in atlanta that's all right
and for all the rhetoric we've heard
about how the media feels unsafe doing
their job as honest brokers because
people make memes of donald trump in a
wrestling match punching a person with
cnn's logo photoshopped over his face
when blm attacks them and is literally
riding at their front doors and breaking
into their building it's well come on
it's not big of a deal it's mostly
peaceful they were like we it is fine we
understand um you know
remember the most he's like they are
mostly peaceful and the police stations
on fire behind them yeah iconic
it was even iconic during the riots of
like uh black business owners having to
put signs saying this is black owned
like yeah burned me down and i i know
drew you remember this when we were in
kenosha all the apartment buildings have
having to put signs saying hey kids live
here please don't burn it down that was
they did it again right before the trial
the rittenhouse trial when i went out
there i was driving down those same
streets and the same signs were out
there there was like this senior citizen
home that was like hey old people live
here
we want to be burnt down my favorite was
those college kids that were cheering on
the blm protest and we're like
and then they got a brick through the
window like
we're with you and they kept throwing
more bricks and i'm like this is this is
the true reality of the consequences
that people don't realize that they have
to deal with let me pull up this story
we got from timcast.com house passes
bill to protect family members of scotus
justices 27 democrats voted against it
so of course of course you guys have
heard they're protesting in front of
kavanaugh's house this is a continuation
of that story
they decide to protest in front of just
justice's homes it's illegal to do so an
activist organization publishes
information showing people how to get to
these homes which should i'm assuming is
also illegal the federal government says
nothing they're not gonna they're not
gonna intervene and then genteki comes
out and says well we certainly encourage
this
they're still defending it a dude shows
up to kill kavanaugh
they they say okay oh you're gonna
arrest that guy and now people are still
protesting i watch these videos
of people marching in front of the homes
of kavanaugh and their statements coming
from the neighbors the neighbors said
after what happened especially we don't
know who these people are we don't know
what's going to happen and we're
supposed to just live this way
no they should be arrested
i could not imagine that i want you all
to imagine this like remember what
happened to tucker carlson they went to
his house we're banging on his door and
his wife had to hide in the pantry now
they want to take your guns away yo when
they've got people burning down your
businesses coming to your home and
threatening you and it's happened that
they've gone to people's houses on
numerous occasions and now they're
saying take away their guns red flag
laws let me tell you something you can't
even call the police tim because you've
got to wait outside for 40 minutes
sure sure but but in wisconsin
there was a group of black lives matter
activists
they thought some girls had been
kidnapped they showed up to this house
where they thought the kidnapping
happened and they set fire to it
somewhat the fire got put out by i think
emergency services they set fire to it
again
this same group of people went in front
of another guy's home because apparently
had an altercation with a neighbor they
called him racist so you've got these
same people everybody knows they were
involved in arson someone was and so he
brandishes a shotgun through his window
the police come and arrest him
now look
people outside in front of your home he
felt threatened
there's an argument about whether or not
he should have brandished a weapon i
mean he's in his own home and he's
making a warning and so they said you
can't point a weapon at people but then
it's a question of if these are people
who have set fire to a house and they're
in front of your home
and you're defending yourself like how
would you like imagine this someone's
coming to your property with violent
intentions and you're like i can't point
my weapon at them until after they
attack you so again i don't like the
conflict i don't like that he did it the
point is here's what's gonna happen
you will be in your house
activists and protesters and extremists
will show up and scream at you and then
when you say like back off we are armed
they'll call in a red flag and they'll
say he's a crazy guy with a gun and the
cops will show up and say hand over your
guns
i warned about this in 2018 i said it's
only a matter of time because we were
watching the police not do anything
when one of these group a group of
people will show up to your house and
this is what i was talking about tucker
carlson here's what will happen because
i've watched this happen in real time
you guys have probably seen this too
you'll have a group of 50 people they'll
all be standing back and they'll all be
yelling one guy will will like bang on
the glass then as soon as he does a
bunch of other people start banging on
the glass because someone crossed the
line then they cross with him the glass
breaks then everyone's standing back
like oh the door's open one person will
slowly look in and then someone else
will look in and then the rest of the
crowd will be like oh they're going in
and then they'll start mobbing in we saw
that with those shopping malls during
the riots where it was like i think it
was jake paul or whoever went in and so
what i'm saying is what will happen is
they'll go to someone's house i took a
carlson they're banging on the door
eventually someone's gonna break the
door it's gonna pop open
then you're gonna see the mob mentality
one person's gonna peek in another
person is gonna step in and then
everyone's gonna rush in tim i disagree
with you uh the the police officers
during the blm riots they did do
something they got on their knees and
they put up their fist and they joined
in unison so did the fbi so did the cia
when they were tweeting a support of
black lives matter they were tweeting in
support of marvel movies like like black
panther which somehow was connected in
some kind of weird way so so seeing this
this larger weaponization of the
intelligence agencies seeing these
police officers within the last two to
three years they exposed themselves they
showed exactly who they are they are
agents of the state the state that is
represented by the people in power that
abuse their power for their own
political purposes for their own
financial gain so this is clear as day
and and obviously the same people that
weaponized these intelligence agencies
these police departments to excuse some
of the worst horrible behavior where
dozens of people died are the same ones
that are telling you trust the police
i'm just following orders exactly in
order yeah yeah which is absolutely
illogical that's what those new york
police officers were saying when they
were literally arresting kids for eating
side at a restaurant without vex without
the vaccination i'm just following
orders exactly that's not
you know it's horrible i mean you take
you take a look at but that's by design
that's that that gets pushed by this
agenda because you have these
politicians like the story that we're
talking about calling uh civil wars
among us accusing political opponents of
a civil war that's going to be sparked
by them i think chuck schumer
literally called out kavanaugh in a
video and i'm paraphrasing he said
you're going to feel the wrath or you're
the beginning or some pain or the
whirlwind
but they they see here's the thing is i
think a lot of people
that may not be politically invested
they don't really look into this stuff
as much as we do we're like obsessed
we're just waiting and waiting and
waiting but the average person is just
watching this and maybe thinking like
this is just happening it's just
happening here we are in american
history where something is happening
it's not by design it's not intentional
there's just these political opponents
that are against each other but people
need to understand
these people know what they're doing
chuck schumer when he says that to the
nation knows who he's talking to he
knows the antifa types he knows the far
left extremists are going to hear that
and take it to the next level but they
already get a pass because all these
crooked da's this crooked law
enforcement the crooked fbi the crooked
you name it all these law enforcement
agencies have been radicalized have been
infiltrated by these globalist uh
organizations where they give them a
pass and don't let them do anything so
at the same time it's like this this
continual subversion where you cannot
trust anything where but but that's
where the constitution comes in i i
appreciate the plea i appreciate what
the police can do they make mistakes
they can screw up big time but at the
end of the day you should have the
ability to defend yourself and your
family period because you could call
9-1-1 and they may not make it in time
you could call 9-1-1 and some
officer like in uvalde decides to call a
stand down for 40 minutes outside of a
school and then all these kids get
slaughtered while they're calling 911.
that's human error that's why you need
the ability to defend yourself but this
is why joe biden is coming out and
saying the second amendment is not
absolute it was not meant to be absolute
it is the perfect storm that like i said
they're trying they want they need
something
if it's not the gun grab if it's not roe
v versus wade if it's not climate change
it they they're i don't know what do you
guys think what do you guys think is
what they're just really kind of kind of
like luke said is they want you focus on
the culture war while they just destroy
you know
warfare and right now to be honest like
i think inflation is a gift for the gop
if they could take advantage of it if
you guys even look at the polls right
now uh joe biden with hispanics is
record low with hispanics is the lowest
there's that 26 percent um the last poll
i saw with the uh for blacks were at 34
so even the minorities are not
supporting joe biden that's why i know
jamal bowman he's a lot smarter than
what he's saying that's why he has to do
the civil war stuff to do the divide and
conquer but he knows the working class
is struggling he knows he knows that
hispanics and blacks do not approve of
what joe biden is doing because we all
feel the pain at the pump we all feel at
the groceries and even today guys we
were interviewing um we were
interviewing some people at the gas
station just talking to see how it was
affecting their daily lives and one
woman mentioned to us that she said hey
everything is up and i'm still getting
paid the same and i think that's how you
know that relates to very important
people that's part of the goal yeah i'm
not so convinced that there's a larger
agenda like i don't think there's a
group of people who said in by 2050 we
want these things now we do know there
is like the 2030 agenda like there are
literally groups of people like davos
what i mean to say is i think when it
comes to the political powers and the
corporate powers
some of these groups have ideas of what
they want to see the future like but
they're mostly focused on the here and
now and that is what can we do to reduce
consumption joe biden and the democrats
have literally said they want to do this
joe biden has literally said he wants to
transition off fossil fuels so when you
see them take these actions that
transition us away from fossil fuels and
make everything harder and more
expensive i mean they told you they were
going to do it
so they're amazing he literally told the
nation that food shortages are coming
that's right i don't know
here's what i want to clarify
they're probably looking to the future
and saying here's what i want the future
to look like but what i mean is most of
their actions are based off of what can
we what are we doing today so joe biden
today will say what's going to get
people to stop spending money what's
going to get production to go down
there's too much garbage there's too
much pollution these are the
environmentalists the climate change
people have literally told you they're
going to do it and now it's happening i
mean there's a lot of pawns in that
particular game but there's also a lot
of shot callers so i think we should
understand it in both of those different
perspectives because they both play a
very important role here but as far as
what we're seeing i mean they've been
talking about this for a very long time
they name it different things but
essentially when you boil it down it's
about human enslavement it's about
getting rid of human rights it's about
getting rid of people's wealth and
that's exactly what the policies they
have been implementing to a point where
biden's senior advisor gina mccarthy
came out today and said people who
criticize this green transition this
green energy transition needs to be
censored on big tech social media she
advocated for the censorship of this
criticism which she is calling this
green
transfer uh so so again what we're
seeing here just like you were
mentioning earlier tim is a transition
that they want that they're implementing
there's going to be a lot of pain and
suffering associated with it but they
don't they don't want you knowing that
it's directly caused by them yeah so i
want to make a point here you guys are
sort of talking about social issues
being a distraction and i disagree that
that's all they are but i would agree
with you that in this particular
situation that's almost certainly the
reason that the left is trying to cling
to every different social issue they can
come into contact with so i believe that
these issues are actually really
significantly important to the long-term
health of our nation but obviously right
now the way the reason they're picking
them out is because they're just looking
for something that they can find to
ingratiate themselves with the american
public because people are not happy with
them and
people are going to blame them for
everything that's going wrong under
their watch and so
even with the issues where they would
like to argue they're politically
popular we've talked about this on the
show a couple times before but when it
when it comes to abortion they'll say
something like well you know there are
many pro-choice americans so maybe if we
talk about abortion enough in the fact
that roe might be overturned we could
win some votes but then they take the
most radically far-left pro-abortion
position they can and they turn off a
lot of pro-choice people so
they don't even know how to win on
social issues anymore and on top of that
with the economy as horrible as it is
your average person is saying how can i
feed my family if this gets worse and
the left does not have an answer for
them other than this actually isn't bad
or it's transitory or deal with it so
let me pull this up here from real clear
politics we have president biden's job
approval it's currently at 38.9 it is
abysmally low it is just this is
apocalyptic for the president here's
what i want to mention
so uh uh you know sheamus you were
talking about how
the left will take the most far-left
position on many things which which
drives moderates away but i think we got
a bigger problem
what they're betting on is
people are too scared to resist no
matter what so they can say the craziest
thing because in fact the crazy scares
people when you've got a president
with a with an approval rating of 38.9
you'd think
every late night comedian would come out
and be like this president sucks
you think every regular person at the
water cooler would be like wow biden's
trash isn't he why it's a safe bet
most people don't like the guy 54.7
disapproval in aggregate it's safe to
say nobody likes the guy yet for some
reason they still defend him the media
still comes out and protects him i i
posted a tweet from the hill they were
like despite the economic rebound i'm
like are you not
are you crazy stop defending this guy
this is the issue they can push any
insane policy they want because people
will not deviate
even if they deep down hate them they
get a call from a pollster do you like
the president no what's interesting
would you tell your friends they're
bought and paid for they can't no it's
interesting if you guys even watch um
like i always pay attention to the
spanish media and if you're watching
like telemundo and univision you feel
like you're watching fox news now
because they have been completely upset
at how they they destroyed the the
working class and like i said um you
know shout out to my latinos we have
biting at 26. um we have them at the low
we have them at the lowest um but i i'm
telling you right now even that media
like i said turn on telemundo and you
feel like you're watching the spanish
tucker carlson because they were
hammering on biting on every single
episode yeah didn't uh didn't george
soros just spend like millions of
dollars buying out they're very worried
about this man they're worried about the
the reason why they're also worried
about the hispanic vote because they're
also they've been looking at south texas
in 2016 all those all those counties um
in south texas are overwhelming latino
like 80 they all swung to hillary
clinton by over 10 to 15 points it
wasn't even close fast forward to 2020
every single county has swung to the gop
off the issue of the border now the
latino base in down in south texas is
fascinating because you go down there
they do want a wall but at the same time
they'll probably vote for a 15 minute
wage they'll probably vote for a
medicare fraud it's really true working
class but i think i think the the dams
are looking at what's what's going on
and how fast they're losing that latino
vote and they're very worried about you
you had me at george soros
and i mean he's going against desantis
in florida heavily as well that's
another important aspect go ahead the
democrats are going you know we're we're
we're losing the mexican vote let's call
them something they hate look tanks you
guys
this actually part of why i do think
social issues are very important the
democrats know that they are at risk of
losing the hispanic community so what
they're trying to do is erode the
hispanic family as much as they possibly
can so they can get them dependent upon
the welfare state and the way to do that
is to break down gender norms and
barriers in la tinx and terms like that
are an emblematic way of doing something
for like like latino voters the biggest
gift right now that the left is giving
to the to the right when it comes to
latino voters is pushing crt and
transgenderism that turns off hispanic
voters like crazy we just did a mini doc
in london county focusing on how they
basically won their school boards that
was led by salvadorian voters chinese
nationals and in indian immigrants i
think people people forget that and look
as a hispanic i'm telling you right now
a lot of my family members and other
people i know behind closed doors the
majority of hispanics they're not even
on board with same-sex marriage yet let
me look at the stuff i mean you try and
groom a hispanic kid
i guarantee you you're gonna dude that
mom is coming with that chocolate bro
you try and take the hispanics guns away
and you try and touch their kids you
will lose at every single turn but
that's what these people are doing right
now and they think we're stupid they
look us in the eye and they think what
we're dumb and that we're just going to
let these people touch our kids and
groom our kids as if it's normal but
that's not going to happen
performing i want to pull up this uh i
got the real clear politics average from
donald trump alone what do you think
donald trump support well you can see it
now i guess his approval rating after
january 6th
it dropped to 39.3
from
43.7 now
full disclosure donald trump's lowest
point was i believe what was it 37.2 or
37. so it was it was very low at one
point but what i'm saying is after
january 6 trump's approval rating is
39.3
right now joe biden is at 38.9
when the democrats come out and say
january 6. i'm like joe biden right now
is less popular than trump was after
that why are you thinking that's going
to do anything for you it's the economy
stupid you're a bigot tim yeah
it's like look at the polls no he's
right when trump did this like well like
i i shouldn't say when he did it from
their perspective it was fresh in the
minds it just happened trump was still
more popular than biden is now well
i think well but why lean on that
messaging exactly i think that there's a
clear reason for it right so the
argument that the left makes about what
was being done to the the capital by the
right on january 6th
is what the left is actually doing to
every american household right now they
are destroying people's ability to
survive and provide for their families
this is what you need you need a video
where like make a cartoon of joe biden
pelosi and schumer like breaking into
people's homes like climbing the barrier
and like waving flags and like regular
people are having their stuff stolen
from them that's it and inflation's the
hidden tax right you print a bunch of
money and then the working-class person
who isn't invested in a bunch of assets
and stocks their savings are totally
devalued and all the people in the the
gigantic corporations who got the
interest-free loans
they get to suck as much value out of
the system as possible and then everyone
else's currency is devalued everyone
else's money loses its value that's what
they did to the american people
well let me just let me just get this
out of the way real quick because uh we
need to appease and please the the cult
so here is our plug
[Laughter]
we just want to make sure that we uh we
worship ukraine we want everyone to know
here that the answer to all of these
problems uh is to give more uh
billions of dollars i think they
deserved 80 billion i think they
deserved 80 billion only 80 you're a
bigot
take all my money all my everything i
have just give it to ukraine because
that's gonna fix our problems how much
how much do you think they should get
jorge
four billion five let's step it up well
you seen it we've seen eighty oh man
trillions you're dollars yeah one
trillion one trillion to zelinski
because he's god and he deserves it
yeah we're all 100 trillion we should
all just worship him right now get on
our knees take a moment well i think the
ukraine things write a song i think i
think the ukraine thing is out yeah it
is like it's already out of people's
courses
various downloads is a download think
about how insane this political cycle is
where it's like world war iii may begin
and a month later they're like what war
it's like what's you like my gas cost
i don't care anymore world war iii is
coming oh wait no no no it's gonna be a
civil war between us and the gop they're
gonna spark it how do people not see
this how do they know it's like world
war three we're on the verge wait no
it's a civil war just kidding that's the
narrative we're going with because we're
in a midterm year and you know we suck
and biden's approval rating is like just
so low and trump's not in office so we
can't use him to radicalize so we just
we got to come up with something i'd be
willing to bet you see all these polls
this is what they do they'll say you
know 80 percent of republicans and
democrats agree on universal background
checks and i'm like
that's not how polls work what they'll
do is they'll go to someone and say do
you think there should be a background
check on gun sales then most people will
say yes and then they'll say they'll add
the word universal later they'll ask you
a question in a way that's very vague
and then make it whatever you know
whatever answer they want but i tell you
this if you were to ask most people on
the right do you think we should have
more gun laws or less they probably say
less yeah where are the republicans who
are negotiating with democrats on gun
access it doesn't exist the republican
party democrats go on the speed limit
i agree so when they when they win
there's no there's no civil war when the
gop went well actually yeah i mean mitch
mcconnell is not charging into battle
right if there's a civil war but maybe
maybe jamal was right because maybe what
happens is republicans win and then
everyone on the right is like yay and
then mitch mcconnell goes now we're
gonna do nothing and then you get a
bunch of really angry people on the
right who are just like i'm done i'm not
participating anymore but
the thing is they can't distinguish
between the two groups right so to them
anyone who is to the left of them is an
evil bigoted irredeemable fascist and so
whether you're talking about mitch
mcconnell or someone who like actually
is conservative and isn't really being
represented by him they're all in the
same camp so in their mind well of
course they're all going to be on the
same side because they're all on the bad
team i mean cocaine mitch literally
killed the the presidential election for
trump when he came out and said you know
all those all those georgia voters if
you guys remember that senate race they
wanted that was at that time that that
2k check and uh yeah mitch mcconnell
just came out and said you know they're
not going to get in that stimulus if
republicans win and i thought that was
r.i.p i mean he could at least lie like
the dams did you know they were like hey
yeah we'll give you that 2k check when
we're in and then they never got the 2k
check
i just don't view it as republican and
democrat anymore i just think it is i
mean as a young kid that's how you're
raised to view things and you start to
view politics like that but this agenda
is on both sides you're seeing it people
like mitch mcconnell are bought and paid
for by china that's freaking obvious so
a lot of this stuff makes sense when you
see where their money's coming from
where this uh cargo shipping company
look at their values their political
what they run on or anything like that
it's like what are they doing and what
are these two drew actually doing is it
like a lot of reps in america yeah a lot
of republicans come out and be like oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna fight big tech and
break it up but then you look at like
their donations it's like you're
literally owned by silicon valley bro
let me let me show you guys this poll
this is uh civics
which party is concern is more concerned
with people like you of all demographics
39 say democrats 36 they republicans and
22 percent say neither here's where it
gets fun though
65 year olds and up and what do they say
43 republican 42 democrats and 13
neither what do you think is going to be
the most dom is going to be the dominant
for the 18 to 34 year olds
who's got to guess
i think neither
18 or 34 year old it is
it's actually democrats wow but neither
is number two at 31
31
of people aged 18 and 34 say neither
party is more concerned with people like
people guess what that doesn't just mean
republicans these are young progressives
and young conservatives
so
republicans are losing either way at 26
but you've got democrats
18 to 34 year olds say democrats you
know republicans conservatives
libertarians moderates terrible at
messaging it's got to change
i mean this is this i mean when i see
this it's a perfect opportunity for the
populist left and the populist right to
unite yeah we can't agree on every
single thing you know not all the
cultural social issues but at least on
the on the you know working class issues
i don't think so
the the populist left and right are
the core of what the fight is so
it's it's mostly the young it's mostly
the younger generations and
overwhelmingly they support political
assassination and revolution according
to splc at least
the older crowd disagrees with each
other but they very much believe in like
we'll just win next year you know we'll
win at the next election
what we're seeing now with young people
some dude jumped to kavanaugh's house
trying to kill him kidnap him and kill
him
and
yo that story was like a page 30 for the
new york times i mean
they put that thing on the back burner
that's scary in it
so you can see what's going on right now
and and this is why they you know this
jamal talks about civil war it's like
well look
he's not necessarily wrong but you got
to think about it from the real
perspective not his perspective and that
is
when you have a dude literally try to
kidnap or prepare plan and try to
execute the kidnapping and assassination
of a sitting supreme court justice and
his family because and his family
because of roe v wade potentially
getting row and casey potentially
getting overturned
the protesters who are in front of his
house hold the exact same views as him
and the government protects those people
not not the guy with the murder he got
arrested and charged but the people who
are in front of his house basically a
threat
the federal government is defending
people breaking the law for political
terroristic purposes
why would any young libertarian moderate
conservative think that they have a
chance
i think there's an opportunity if people
can win in the primaries and you're
seeing a lot of trump's picks are
winning so we'll see what happens after
this november but i think this 31
percent neither is particularly
dangerous that's showing that regular
people are like the system is broken i'm
i'm not playing this game anymore mm-hmm
whereas i think i think a lot of people
that watch this show are probably in
that category i mean i think
when you see this stuff happening people
that are actually paying attention
that's kind of where you land you see
what's happening with the left you're
like yeah i'm i'm not down with you know
killing babies outside of the womb and
you take a look at what's happening with
conservatives and republicans and you're
like yeah
uh i don't like how they're trying to
take my guns and you guys like aren't
doing anything about it so i think
that's how you end up in this place
which
could be a actually is a good thing
because it brings people back to a place
where it is just more of independence i
would say for sane mighty thinking
people but if the more extreme part of
that percentage is probably going to go
more towards revolution so it's it like
you say tim i think it it's a very
interesting time to be alive to see
where this goes well i want to mention
this you're sort of mentioning you said
you don't really see a difference
between the democrats and republicans
and when it comes to elected leaders i
completely agree i still believe that
there are very firm lines drawn between
the left and right and that these terms
are significant and important but part
of what i find really fascinating is
that the one issue which i found is
tremendously popular among people both
left and right or at the very least was
more popular prior to ukraine was
opposing foreign intervention and yet
when you look at the the republican
democratic parties they both almost
always support it
and so when you have one issue where
people on the left and right actually
tend to agree the republican and
democratic party are on the exact
opposite side of that issue never forget
5 29.
never ever we need to have those 529
hearings
yeah but we act unironically we do but
there are some things that that do bring
us together
hatred for the valley police
department that one does jeffrey epstein
uh that's another one that brings people
together because these are the core
issues that highlight just the
corruption of the state the corruption
of authority and why you should never
entrust people with your safety with
being able to protect yourself as an
individual yeah yeah but but hold on
right
many of these people on the left who
were acting shocked about epstein
defended and voted for hillary clinton
they defend and vote for the
establishment they come out and they're
like yeah yeah we know about you know
him flying on that plane all those times
but uh you know vote for his wife but
they make the same argument about donald
trump saying that epstein and trump were
wingmen that they were together that
they were partying since the 80s so from
their point of view they're bringing
that up as well from their point of view
they're wrong because while you
certainly do have the hardcore monkey
types you also have people saying
desantis over trump you have people
people on the post liberal libertarian
right mode or whatever are saying yeah
maybe it's not trump maybe maybe it's a
desantis on the left they're like the
machine should be protected
so when they come out and they say
epstein was bad i'm like you don't
believe that you support everyone you're
defending big corporations you're
defending unaccountable uh big tech
revolving door policies everything
that's the left was supposedly
protesting all of a sudden they flip on
stop and frisk remember when that was
bad red flag laws are the exact same
thing on steroids you think it's bad
when they're going up to young black men
in new york city and frisking them and
chasing them through the streets because
bloomberg said target the black minority
what do you think is going to happen
with red flag laws in new york city now
they're going to kick their doors in and
go in their houses so when they come out
and they're like we we are united on
this one no you're not they're lying
that i do not believe them for two
seconds now if they want to come out and
point to the small group relative of
like hardcore trump supporters who seem
to just say trump can do no wrong by all
means go ahead and say that but that's
the exception on the right not the rule
on the left it's the rule not the
exception so what does bring us together
well what can
the identity of the left is is solely
hating the right that's why when stop
and frisk is is like when red flag laws
are their issue they all of a sudden are
like stop and frisk is a good thing now
they're not literally saying stop and
first is a good thing but there's
literally no difference there's no
principle there's no morality it's just
what does my side fight for and we'll
accept that again on the right it's the
exception not the rule and this is
likely because moderates post liberals
and libertarians are associated with the
right these days i'm sure there's a
bunch of zealous conservatives who would
side with whatever conservative cause
and you see them on twitter sometimes
but again rule exception exception rule
there's also a lot of people that just
say everything the corporate media wants
them to say wants them to believe wants
them to regurgitate the next thing
whether it's a blm flag or pride flag or
ukrainian flag they they fly all of them
without even questioning it but but what
about the people who are in the middle
what about the people that we just
looked at who who are disenfranchised
what what's the common ground that we
could agree with in the middle of the
right
yeah well but i mentioned this earlier
when i was talking about sort of the
differences between the left and right
and the differences with the democratic
republican parties i think the warfare
issue i think most americans consider
foreign are
totally opposed to foreign intervention
i would say unfortunately i think you're
either gonna learn through like
knowledge uh or wisdom and just
take the examples of history for what
they really are and to learn from our
mistakes and to learn from what's
happened in the past to other countries
and different time frames uh in history
that's one way
but i think the second way is learning
through experience and i think
unfortunately where we are right now as
a country that
i don't know i think maybe one of the
worst things that we could see happening
is obviously full
authoritarian global overreach on this
country which at that point
will definitely unify everybody because
when that boot is on everybody's neck
together there's no getting out of it
there's no more talking about it anymore
there's no more uh saying this is a
conspiracy theory there's no more
pointing the fingers anymore because
once that happens
that's where we are when you're in a
gulag when the full government is on top
of you i think at that point it's like
where do you go from there other than
okay we got some serious tyranny here
that's that's one way that's not where i
want to see the country go but i think
that'll unify it reminds me of this one
time
when we were covering uh a riot in
louisville and uh we were undercover we
were you know around antifa and black
lives matter
and uh the police decided to kettle
everybody
and uh we all got kettled the media the
rioters everyone got kettled in one
second you explained cuddling for people
foreign is when the police they just
begin to organize whether they do it on
the street they start to strategically
target a group of people to put them in
one corner they'll shut down boxes
intersections box everybody in to make
mass arrests right so they did that to
the rioters this one time and we got
caught up in it and we got arrested and
uh we were thrown
shelby telco was there too and we were
all thrown in a cell
with antifa rioters black lives matter
rioters and it was kind of like a you
know it could it could have gone bad for
us if they found out who we were
but it reminded me of this situation
where we were all
we the boot came down on all of us it
didn't matter it didn't matter who i was
i was telling the police
i'm drew hernandez listen i'm not a
writer i'm an undercover reporter like
oh
just just tell the co when you get in
there who you are and you should be fine
i go in there and when i tell them what
the officer told me to tell him he's
like oh just just just don't show them
your face
so i was like yeah that's not great
something bad could happen to me in
there but when we were all in there
everyone was the same you were just a
number the boot came down on everybody
it didn't matter what side you were on
and for a moment it was like unifying
it's not that i believed in what they
believed in but it brought us to this
point where it's like okay there's
something here that's all against us and
it's not a i'm just trying to use it as
an example as like how tyranny could
really bring everyone together because
at that point you're just all screwed
but i i disagree because as i already
mentioned if 38.9 of people approve of
biden
most people should be should be speaking
out against them as i mentioned late
night talk show hosts would be like
we're going to get more advertising
dollars because this is the popular
position they don't do it we're not
there yet i kind of actually i i kind of
agree with tim because i was in dc the
the day that um biden won the election
and i remember going down there to dc
and i'm filming on reporting and i see
all these liberals in their master
popping champagne they're drinking and i
kind of had that moment of like wait a
minute hold on
these same people who were the anti-war
against corporations just voted in the
guy who voted us into iraq committed war
crimes i mean he joe biden if you guys
remember back in 0302 was side by side
with george bush all giddy to get us
into the iraq war i'm like wait a minute
in 97 yeah i'm like wait a minute these
liberals who are anti-war against war
crimes against corporations are popping
champagne to this guy i think that
moment i said i think i lost hope for
the other side yeah biden wanted that
war a lot longer pre-911 as far back as
1999 oh he was giddy man he couldn't
wait to send a an 18 year old from
kansas uh to the middle east so we could
protect their opium fields he couldn't
wait but i do want to make one point so
you said there was kind of this unifying
effect of being in a cell with these
people on the left but ultimately you
still had to hide your face
because you knew what would happen if
they knew who you were so i don't know
that i could agree
that there will be units not that i
believed in what they believed in not
that no that's not what i'm saying what
i'm saying is like in the moment you're
put in the same situation when there is
some kind of
force against you but putting you all in
one cell but i guess my point is once
they
have more information on you you're not
uniting together to fight the system
they're uniting together to fight you
yeah
but still we're put in the same position
let's talk about this freedom for a
moment this story here we got from the
daily beast
now uh the daily basis fake news as
newsguard says right here they say uh
you know is fake news perceive questions
and they claim
the biggest migrant caravan on collision
course with trump-era border order scott
bigsby white house reporter now i can't
i can't prove this is real because
newsguard says dailybeast is fake but uh
can you guys tell me about what's going
on the border is this the daily beast
actually for once publish a real story
so i mean what would i kill what i could
say about the caravan i'm speaking with
some sources in mexico so the caravan
right now is between 10 000 to 15 000
people now the reason why we always see
caravans and kind of rolling in in the
kind of these mass groups is because
they're technically not allowed to
travel legally through mexico so that's
why they wrote they kind of go together
like that they could overpower
authorities what the mexican officials
did and we've been trying to report on
it
is they actually granted these people
work visas so for the first time this
caravan is actually legally allowed to
travel through mexico meaning they could
hop on buses they could hop on taxis
because normally um when you're not
allowed to legally travel through mexico
as a migrant the mexican police actually
kick you off buses and train so this
group is actually legally allowed to
travel now because they are legally
allowed to travel we're not going to see
the 15 000 hit the border all at once
it's going to be more spread out they
are going to reach the board a little
bit quicker and according to our sources
they're going to be most of them going
to be arriving through
south texas now one thing that i did
reporting on my last border trip we were
there for title 42 is if you guys
remember back in april texas governor
greg abbott made four agreements with
four different mexican state governors
along the border to beef up security
stop the flow of drugs and all that
stuff ever since then abbott has gone on
and touted that that agreement as a
success we've literally spent time in
mexico all over through those areas and
then we we we just literally uh
published the investigation you guys
have to check it out but we expose that
the mexican authorities don't even do
anything i mean we were literally
jumping in the water with the migrants
crossing in with them and everything we
were embedded with these groups and the
mexican authorities don't even listen to
any of abbott's orders the only day that
the mexican officials set up authorities
on the riverbanks and stop stop
migration is when governor greg abbott
visited eagle pass so then the mexican
security set it up and pedestrians right
across and they put up a little show for
greg abbott but after that they don't
even listen to the united states
president amo didn't even attend the
summit of americas in los angeles
president of osavo naibu kelly uh
president of guatemala and honduras have
been very upset with with uh vice
president kamala harris and her handling
of the border crisis because uh naibu
kelly the president of salvador says my
goal is to keep the salvadorans in el
salvador but when you guys do the open
border policy well the human smokes are
going to take over so
you have four presidents that are very
key in this migration debate who didn't
even attend the summit america's i think
that's a huge loss foreign policy for
the bible yeah it's creating a loss of a
lot of brain drain and a lot of people
don't realize that this immigration
debate is far more complex than hey just
people want to come over here there's a
lot of other economic effects especially
when it comes to cheapening labor
especially when it comes to housing
costs going up especially with the
increase of immigration that are going
to have a net effect on the larger
economic picture that we're all dealing
with so it's far more complex and
there's far more things intertwined in
this that we don't even know that we're
that we're not even debating and talking
about and discussing
i wanted to ask you something you
mentioned that they've actually been
given the work visas to travel through
mexico this time why did that happen you
know the mexican officials because one
thing that they do is they don't like it
when a bunch of migrants are basically
in their towns so like basically the
first town that the migrants hit is
tapachula so they would do is they hit
tapachula and the mexican officials stop
them there and they said you're not
allowed to travel and basically what
happens is more migrants come and they
kind of kind of create a bottleneck i
don't know if you guys remember last
year when those 15 000 haitians all
arrived in del rio texas at once they
all started off in in tapachula but the
officials in top of chile got so
overwhelmed they just gave them work
like literally visas were like dude just
just leave and then all those haitians
traveled together and they ended up
crashing the borders so that's one thing
that this president president of mexico
he feels no pressure from biden to do
absolutely anything and then the mexican
authorities are making a fool out of
greg abbott that's what we're trying to
try to expose in a report you know you
have we have a republican governor who's
touting his agreements as a success
where we're literally jumping in the
water with with migrants like we're
literally you know crossing crossing
with them and you know for a lot of
people uh watching this you might think
well look i live in ohio i live in
michigan i live in pennsylvania i'm not
a border town i don't care well you
might not be impacted by the migrants
you know coming in and drug smugglers
being car chases but that fentanyl still
is still coming into your state i mean
the number one state impacted by
fentanyl right now is ohio and it's
impacting the white working class you're
not gonna hear that on mainstream media
because any any issue that that impacts
white working class they they don't even
cover but but the phenol issue has
become really a top concern that we've
been trying to cover even my own
hometown in palmdale i covered a
fentanyl death of a 22 year old guy
named jordan erickson he popped his knee
at a gym and a local came up to him and
gave him an oxycodone and said hey
jordan take this 24 hours later jordan
was dead because it was a counterfeit
pill and we're seeing that phenomenon
with 13 year olds right now where they
think they're taking xc the first time
they think they're taking a vicodin ends
up being a counterfeit pill and the
thing guys with fentanyl there's no
second chance you know so it's uh it's
we're in some scary times
absolutely uh there's also a big haitian
community in tijuana because there's
been a lot of uh you know mass migration
that was happening in that town and in
that town you know the locals don't like
having to deal with this influx of of of
people i remember doing reporting on the
ground in tijuana and seeing this kind
of these kind of man-made camps that
they were building that were
have you seen those
make
there was rallies there was rallies
specifically in tijuana calling for
better uh immigration laws because we're
seeing victims the victims or the people
who are told come across everything's
going to be great
corporations are taking advantage of a
lot of this cheap labor that they're
extorting and exploiting especially when
it comes to new people coming into this
country so you know this thing is far
more complicated than than we even
allowed and i just
and then people are also being flown in
and bused in all over the united states
not just on the border towns i just want
to mention this this quick detail
because it's important for the audience
to know uh on the last trip that me and
drew actually did in yuma together we
were reporting we were running into
massive groups around three in the
morning crossing in and right hundreds
and hundreds and hundreds and i think
for people who maybe don't understand
immigration you probably think oh well
they're coming from el salvador
guatemala honduras we interviewed those
migrants they came from 11 different
countries me and drew ran across
russians afghanistan lots of men coming
from india i mean and it was single
males and and yeah georgia and then you
do an interview with them and like hey
are you guys you know worried that
you're gonna be deported under title 42
and they're like no
not not in this administration we're
welcome and even the border patrol their
morale is low because they don't even
guard the border anymore now immigrants
i mean if you guys ever go down to the
border it's fascinating immigrants cross
the border and look for the border
patrol i mean back in the day you know
immigrants cross the border and you want
to invade the border they look for the
border patrol because they they want to
be apprehended and they know they're
going to get released in the united
states i had one border patrol and told
me said jorge i don't even feel like a
border patrol agent i'm just an uber
driver right now they're literally uber
an uber service i mean
what's interesting too to go to luke's
point is
i talk to some of these mexicans down
there right because they'll be there on
the border on the other side
and uh the last time we were down there
in yuma i was talking to one of them and
i was like obviously this has gone up
right since biden he's like way up
you're local here he's like yes it's
gotten worse under biden and i was like
how do the mexicans feel about illegal
immigration like mexicans right he's
like we hate it we hate these people
coming in because it activates the
cartels
they're dirty
there the pollution is insane the
garbage that's thrown everywhere all the
clothes and the trash he says they're
very entitled people they're very lazy
people they come to all the mexicans
locally and they trash their communities
just like the haitians that are
occupying in tijuana right they trash
their communities and they're just
entitled and they run around to the
mexicans saying give me money they
demand money they demand they're feeling
titled to everything so it's it's
interesting when you talk to some of the
mexicans and you're like
i think the media will paint them like
oh they just everyone wants to come into
the united states but some of the locals
there are like dude we hate these people
coming well the haitians have actually
assimilated into the tijuana community
and have their own neighborhoods there's
there's a whole
culinary kind of you know street and and
this was because they thought they were
going to go to the united states there
were strict border patrols um that that
were uh you know used uh they were stuck
in tijuana and they created a community
there and and uh they're working
cohesively there but you know you do
talk to a lot of mexicans mexicans who
are proud of their country who love
their country and they're troubled
because this brings crime this brings
violence and and human extortion which
is absolutely horrible no one wins out
of this except for the multinational
corporations and the politicians who are
using this as a way to get more power
out of it and this is all on the backs
of so much suffering so many people are
getting screwed over and and that's the
aspect here that people really need to
understand the human cost to all of this
i don't know if you remember luke back
in i think it was like oh six bernie
bernie sanders was doing an interview
and the journalist asked him you know
why don't you support uh open borders
and even bernie says like wait a minute
why would i support open borders that
that's what the corporations want that's
like
yeah yeah yeah yeah and right there the
journalist was like oh my god this
progressive and i mean even bernie knows
even bernie knows but i mean now he
won't say it because of kyle kind of
crazy the the left has got there but
even bernie knew bernie the koch
brothers are doing this to us but this
is we see this all the time we see this
all the time with the left in the united
states and we've talked about it when it
comes to women's liberation for example
they'll say we are just bleeding heart
people who have everyone's best
interests in mind and that's why we want
to make changes to the social order it's
like okay well then women enter the
workforce in mass and wages stagnate
because you've doubled the workforce and
then they go well we just want to bring
more people into our country because
they're all asylum seekers and we want
to improve their lives oh my goodness
also it happens to be the case that the
neoliberal elite is going to make an
insane profit off of all of these people
coming to the country who are used to
third world wages and those are going to
be the folks competing with your average
american for labor and for jobs you give
them citizens
i know i'm such a i'm an unbelievably
horrid person
bernie sanders is just funny to me
because uh he's you know he's out of
vermont right pretty sure yeah yeah
and in vermont they have some like
really great gun laws he and he was
against gun control and now he's like i
think this bipartisan build doesn't go
far enough we need more gun control and
i'm like bernie what happened is it
lucky martin
have a major factory in vermont i think
it's lockheed uh i have to double check
that
no one needs guns except the cartels to
bring those asylum seekers over those
are the only people who need cops and if
you're going to cross illegally just
wear your mans you can stay six feet
away from the border patrol
bernie sanders know what they done split
me because i have four houses of course
they have three houses he has three this
is what i find hilarious right when you
bring up the fact that bernie sanders
has three houses they go well that's not
hypocrisy he's just a socialist who has
houses he doesn't live in it's like okay
if i had three houses and i rented two
of them out you'd be calling me a
landlord and a parasite he has three
houses
just keeps two of them empty most of the
time and he's a philanthropist yeah what
about all the migrants what about all
the homelessness all the homeless
pirates i just think the migrants in
there i just think it's hilarious
that owning a house and making use of
your capital by renting it out to other
people so someone who can't get a
mortgage is able to live there is evil
and makes you a parasite but having
extra houses and just keeping them empty
in case you want to go there on a whim
is perfectly moral and ethical and how
dare you even question the fact that
that's how bernie sanders lives while
calling himself a socialist we need to
get according to his wants that's right
if you write
if you write a best-selling book of
course
mark said that to each according to
their needs
from each according from their to each
according to the needs from each point
of their ability and to those who are
really good at writing books which you
know marx also wrote a bestseller i
guess so that's why that's right that's
why i love also
bernie sanders is
i know that like if you write a
best-selling book you're just entitled
to all the profits from it but i'm
curious like what about the people who
had to uh cut down the trees and and
obtain the lumber that was then
converted into the paper for that book
like shouldn't they get you know a
proportional share of the profits that
it made why is it just the guy who puts
the ink on the page
that makes all the money let's talk
economics huh so we're talking about
civil war earlier i saw this tweet from
matt kors he says prepare for a crash
and he's referencing jim cramer saying
why we're buying stocks heading into
wednesday's big fed decision
you know what this sounds like to me the
federal reserve oh the federal reserve
is trending let's see if they if they
raise rates
when when when the tv tells you to buy
they're like it's not a recession bye
it's because the rich people are
offloading and the break is gonna happen
yeah he made some crazy calls in 2008
that were absolutely wrong and have
obliterated people's personal finances
look it's like claire stearns get a
bunch of it this is probably yeah
this is uh this is from yesterday
morning
every stock in the s p 500 is red right
now oh my gosh so when they're like no
no we're buying right now with the fed's
decisions gonna raise rates and tank the
market now i don't know man the
challenge is
raising interest rates to try and deal
with inflation
what else do you do do you just let uh
what do you do well it's difficult right
because this is what they always do
every single time the stock market is
declining they print a bunch of money to
artificially inflate the price of stocks
but of course that
in the long run as we just saw inflates
the cost of everything else so with
inflation out of control i have no idea
what they're even going to attempt to do
we're just building back better yeah
they're just building back better baby
it's almost like it's almost like
they're gonna have to reset things in
some some way
it's almost like we have to live in the
pods and eat the bugs let's talk about
this it's going well i love it it's
building back better uh property price
prices plunge by the 20 percent across
parts of the us
we got red uh real estate firms compass
and redfin announced layoffs as housing
markets slows and then we get coinbase
dropping eighteen percent of its debt
the crypto market we get because crypto
took a major hit but apparently what
they're saying is we are entering a
recession this is what they're saying
you know they didn't have to do this
but it appears we're entering a
recession housing markets getting hit
stock market's getting hit building back
better apparently means wiping out all
of the gains of the past two years
driving gas prices up to five bucks a
gallon making sure you can't work and
sending billions of dollars to uh to
ukraine to to fund war hold on to be
fair to be fair it's gonna go up
to way more than five dollars a gallon
oh that's a good point yeah yeah maybe
maybe seven by august i mean i'm already
where i live in palm low california
we're like 6 39. so we're already at
what a sophisticated and well-run state
i hope they tell florida what kind of
policies they have right
the only thing saving me is that good
weather
that's about it
i love it i love it klaus rob told me
that i will own nothing and be happy and
that's how i feel right now i was like i
already own nothing when you're gonna
make me happy that's how i feel i feel i
feel happy right now this this biden
loves me i'm a stupid mexican i can't
think for myself i can't vote for myself
i i can't figure out how to go get a
voter id and i'm poor someone's going to
clip that oh my money just sucks my bank
account is horrible i have nothing to
own nothing to show for myself tim i am
so happy well let's just build back here
it only applies i love it it only
applies okay the klaus killer white
supremacist cops are hunting me
everywhere i go and it's just it's just
going oh no no it only applies if you're
poor
i am poor tim oh
drew i'm not sure
i am poor i give my money to zielinski i
donate religiously what is going on
right now i left the christian church
and i went to the church of zielinski i
give like tithing to him every single
month listen i'm out of the cult tim buy
an electric car right it's only 60
dollars
are you important
emails
i tried to get one but it didn't work so
i'm trying to email biden to get one
next and it's it's it will get it sounds
like you don't want to build back
batteries i am building back better
that's what you guys don't understand
you guys are all the crazy ones every
single one of you in this room i i am
the same this is the only one such a
bigot
i got the download in my brain you guys
didn't get the update i have the most
recent update the new thing the new
thing you guys don't even know what it
is you know the thing
i want to mention one thing i find this
hilarious right because you'll have like
talk show hosts like stephen colbert and
other people on the left who will say if
you're worried about gas prices just get
an electric an electric car when like
obviously that's ridiculous if someone's
having trouble affording gas they can't
afford an electric car but also it's not
as if having an electric car exempts you
from the widespread economic
consequences of high gas prices food's
going to get more expensive dude energy
costs are going to just wait for the
black out charge that car wait for the
burnout to blackout
right now yeah they're like well i have
an electric car tampons who needs
tampons right wasn't that a story yeah
tampon shortage but but but women could
just use rags can't they yeah
i'm the greatest woman you guys have
ever seen
don't you guys know it takes a great man
to be a real woman they play
thomas and freaking taylor like didn't
what happened with her with the
skateboarding hey hey don't disrespect
leah thomas all right let's let's let's
just keep it on there economic collapse
the shoulders otherwise we're gonna
we're kind of going crazy they just had
to put well they had to put a hold on
all women's products until we can figure
out what a woman is exactly okay it's
the end of the world we might as well
enjoy it right we got mass layoffs
and it's happening in the housing market
first
crypto is kind of like it's its own
thing uh i'm not selling crypto you know
i i think crypto's going down the same
as most things are going down
but
what's going to come next with high gas
prices with a recession
i hope you all are getting prepared
i don't know exactly what that means do
you buy 30 years of the beans i don't
know don't look at me all i know is
it is gonna get worse
because they're telling us it's gonna
get worse because they said you will own
nothing you know what nothing means
nothing owning nothing means you won't
have a can of beans that's right so it
says when you're hungry you might find
yourself in a walmart parking lot
fighting with agnes over that last can
well but there's this really smart guy
who told me bread lines are a good thing
because it means you have community yeah
red lights was that burnt lines are a
good thing it's like well that's really
easy to say when you have like three
houses right
i have three loaves of bread one for
each house dude when he went so he's
hilarious he went to the ussr on his
honeymoon and i'm not kidding you one of
the things he said praising the soviet
government was that there were
inexpensive puppet shows
i just want that to sink in that is a
little bit it's like well look the
puppet shows were very inexpensive you
know they've got gulags but a puppet
show it's cheap you go there you get to
see the the puppets talk with each other
it's charming quite frankly did he
really say this yes he said they had
cheaper he was going on with a list of
all the wonderful things that were
happening in the ussr and one of them
was he he praised these cheap puppet
shows he's like they the only camera is
like 1.50 you get to watch a puppet it's
incredible what
every other developed nation has cheap
puppet shows but the united states why
is that why aren't we talking to you
blackrock is going to own everything man
including the vr that's going to be the
gulag entertainment is puppet shows by
bernie sanders you guys i think i'm
kidding look up the ussr and bernie
sanders in puppet shows look it up all i
know is oh if anyone he's kind of sad to
talk was in the gulag i'm your boy cause
we're smoking
bernie bernie is like in we got to
figure this
out they have cheap puppet shows and i'm
and there's the other guy's just in
there he's like i was i was i was just
watching the simpsons
it was free can you tell me how to get
how to get i saw something straight you
guys know the shawshank redemption yes
you know like red he's like the go-to
guy to get your stuff i could picture
tim being read in the gulags when they
come tim's going to be like the go-to
don't give him to get your stuff to get
you connected to whatever you need
absolutely not true tim's the guy i'm
going to be you're going to be the
shadows minding my own business now
you'll be the guy no i won't be
no i'll be just sitting in the back and
someone will walk up to me and i'll be
like don't open your mouth keep walking
i i could see sheamus using his i'm not
going to go what is that
is this sometimes this is a lot of gold
reference do you think they're going to
let us know i was going to say a prison
wallet but that's another discussion
come on i thought you're going to make a
potato reference or something i just
want to say by the way with this
inflation stuff i mean i've got a pot of
gold so i can't find you're set yeah
i'm just kidding i don't i don't have
any assets
so yeah but if i did those would also be
crashing i'm certainly
if i did those would also be crashing
what what are the consequences of this i
mean what do we do and what is the
federal reserve going to do i'm really
i'm faster raise interest rates
because inflation is going insane yeah
and uh
you know i suppose the real issue is
they could encourage more production
we could do more energy development here
at home
instead they're just like me
you know but then people will own
something and not be happy exactly
they'll own stuff and be unhappy i mean
it is true owning stuff makes you
unhappy true we talked about it they did
a a survey a test on people a study
where they said if you complete this
questionnaire you'll get a free t-shirt
one group got to choose between two
different shirts one group was just
given a shirt the group they got to
choose was unhappy because they were
like oh i picked the wrong color i
should have picked the other one the
people were just giving a shirt like
cool free shirt got a shirt yeah it was
the choice
that actually made them all right i'm
gonna be happy in the pod then
they're not gonna let that you choose
they're like there's your pot it's gray
and you're like i like it it's free huh
it's free tell me what you need i just
hope they don't let me choose what kind
of bugs i'm eating
i don't know
the worst the ai does on your phone just
you'll be what you want you'll be like i
should have chose crickets these roaches
are
gross
yeah crickets are crunchier a little uh
put a little little tapatio on them yeah
there you go there you go that's how you
can do it spice it up i gotta just give
you guys a little bit i got you in the
glue
thank you i appreciate that i'm glad
someone yeah
yeah you bring the ir the irish beer i
got the kind of soda you have the irish
food you want irish food though they're
probably serving irish food oh okay all
right yeah yeah yeah okay then i don't
know man i like uh shepherd's pie yeah i
like potatoes every now and again
there's like something good it's like
they make a stew and they top it with
potatoes that's great yeah
that's what they do look all i'm saying
is this we're we are in a you guys want
to make all these jokes we are in a
conundrum here but this i mean look this
is one of the uh inevitable consequences
of an economy which is planned and not
just planned but planned by people who
face zero consequences for making
horrible decisions mm-hmm
this is where we are these people have
always been incompetent even they are
who they look up to in worship can i
make this point
fdr who they look up to in worship this
is the greatest president we ever had
well firstly america had one of these
slowest economic recoveries of any
developed nation coming out of the great
depression but also
he once increased the price of gold by
21 cents and his rationale
was seven three times is a lucky number
that's amazing these were the kinds of
decisions being made for the entire
economy i kind of agree with it
but it's it's not as if we've had it
it's not as if um it's it's a new
phenomenon that the economy is being run
and controlled by people who have
absolutely no clue what they're messing
with
it's just we're seeing some serious
consequences i think they know what
they're doing because it's definitely
some of them
i mean everyone who was responsible for
2008 none of them are held so yeah
they're not held responsible um
it's a broken system but you know who is
held responsible is guys like you know
julian assange you know for like
exposing war crimes and those who who
did the war crimes they don't have to
see they didn't they weren't only just
not held responsible they were promoted
they were given a check they were given
bonuses on top of their financial crimes
that they committed against the people
so so what happened there was paved over
the bubble was made bigger and now we're
all just kind of sitting here waiting
for everything to pop as of course we're
getting the first kind of storm incoming
and i think this is one storm of many to
come and i think you know
we talk about the problems i think maybe
we still got a couple more minutes we
could talk about maybe potential
solutions i think one of the best
currencies you could have is social
currency the friends you have the
relationships you have a family uh your
neighborhood your community i think
focusing on creating pods on
homeschooling your children or is
something that of course will help get
us through these larger storms because
they are coming there's a lot of people
are few you know scared a lot of people
think there's you know resistance is
futile it's not i just i want to let the
record show luke said focus on making
pods
he does want you to live in the podium
yeah somebody's going to continue just
homeschooling that homeschooling pods
luke is a plant
the m1 money supply
has shrunk
check it out
from april
i'm sorry from march at 20 what is it 20
trillion 700 a little bit because you
can't see that i can't i won't be able
to zoom out that sucks okay so
well you can sort of see it no look at
that it dropped by about uh what 40
billion is that maybe that's the 40
billion we gave to ukraine
from march to april
it's like 40 billion out of the money
supply uh but that was like six no no
i'm sorry it was like it's like it's
like 80.
yeah it drops by about 90 actually about
90 billion so uh i wonder if that's
seeing where the recession is coming
because they were just pumping money
into the system trying to keep it going
and they stopped and now everything's
going to fall apart because there's no
real trade happening
so there could be bartering i think
bartering is something that people
should
also kind of look into especially when
it comes to having a community having a
network of individuals that could trade
skills that could trade goods that could
trade services uh you know the free
state project i think is is ahead of its
time they do incredible things when it
comes to uh homeschooling they do
incredible things when it comes to
building communities and i and i think
you know the amish did it in their own
particular way there's no reason other
people other communities can't do it
themselves as well and once we start
becoming personally responsible for
ourselves we don't need government
government would become obsolete if
people were just responsible for
themselves as individuals because we
wouldn't need any government
intervention we wouldn't need anyone
stepping in a way we wouldn't need
anyone saying hey we need big government
for this that's going to make the
problem that much worse um the solution
i i think you know we're headed towards
crazy turbulent times but it doesn't
mean that it can't be an opportunity to
to see the good and to build something
better
there it is again we could reset there
it is again
who you working for
who's sending his checks who's saying
luke's check you know it's funny because
you're right luke has all these videos
where he's confronting very prominent
individuals and there was this one point
where people were like there's no way
luke was actually able to get in front
of like ben bernanke so he must be a fed
oh
and then we did we did this skit that
was really funny no because like a lot
of people were like you know look
without a video where he's like
confronting ben bernanke three times
three times and they're like there's no
way yeah they're like this guy's a plant
and so then we did a bit where luke's
phone rings and it says ben bernanke and
he's like benny what's up man he's like
yeah i'll come hang out i'm using
disguises and like fake names and fake
press credentials fake websites and fake
emails just to get into venues and
events and like staying outside
literally hours on end just waiting for
one politician to maybe go this one
particular way oh yeah so i've been i've
been working my butt off but yeah that
that nose it's not a real nose yeah yeah
well luke actually look actually i got
the same thing myself uh when i covered
the the uvalde shooting a bunch of my
dms were like isn't that weird jorge
that you just happen to be there so i'm
like i was covering the border in eagle
pass which is like an hour away i have a
car
i drove there
i love when people are like isn't it
weird i like yeah like sometimes things
are weird yeah yeah
it was weird like maybe you know because
shows a simulation tim is not real he's
not a real person oh yeah
like if everybody knows this in this
room that if you take his beanie off
right now it'll be like robocop oh
doesn't even know that he's not real no
no no i do and the point is you don't by
saying tim you don't know i do and the
point is
by saying yes the people who are
watching
assume that we're all joking but there's
no way to know if it's true or not
so when we tell you in a stimulation
time when we when we tell people
they will say it must be a joke and
they're all having a laugh but it's real
that's right actually that's the
scariest thing with security is that
people believe that stuff tim paul is
not right and then
the threats the threats we get aren't
antifa
the people who who common causes
problems are just crazy people
like we actually believe it or not after
everything we've done and after
everything that's happened we've still
had people try showing up here yep
give up
and they'll be like i know that like you
get death threats all the time and like
the bomb squad was just here and the
sign says warning we will shoot
intruders but i decided to come on to
your property anyway and i'm like wow
did the armed guard deter you what he
did i'm like that's what we have them
that's that's crazy out there clout
chasers well i gotta say i mean you know
as i've been talking about civil war for
years
it's it's like
i'm kind of the point where watching the
brett kavanaugh stuff is like
you know i feel that
with what we've been dealing with
then i'm just like if they're when they
don't enforce that that pisses me off
because i'm we're seeing something
similar well this kavanaugh
assassination attempt came about a day
after a study was published in the news
which showed that was something like 44
percent of young democratic men support
political assassinations yep and the
fact that they're not stamping out those
literally illegal protests as an attempt
to sway judicial rulings is a sign to me
that they would like to weaponize these
people who like the idea of
assassination lydia why are we wasting
our time doing that we have to chase
down these moms and dads at the school
board meetings yeah that's that's the
real phone that was the real thing yeah
yeah and real threat are the moms and
dads that don't want their children
groomed and touched yeah exactly those
are the people we got to go out
that first amendment is literally the
reason why we have terrorism they
believe they could say whatever they
want they believe they can think
whatever they want
and this is going to shock you guys they
think they have the right to own
firearms
and they think they have the right to
own firearms even
while having
bad opinions that hurt my feelings
opinions yeah yeah i think we hurt your
feelings bro i think we need red flag
laws
will that make you feel better
it would
probably help me feel a little bit
better i don't think i'm really going to
be happy until i own nothing yeah yeah
but it'll make me feel like a little
better yeah we'll be partially there
yeah
yes
so yeah
we
have excuse me announcement we've said
everything there is to say about
politics with the show is over we are
wrapping tim cast up this is our last
episode
we're done we collect everything
solutions again i talked about my
solutions
the solution is to have klaus schwab
live in studio with tim poole and luke
and sheamus and everybody else that's
the thing i would love to the klaus
schwab luke rutkowski debate yes and
bill gates our savior and our god
yes
elon musk be you guys see lauren
southern's documentary based amazing no
but i've seen a trailer for it i've seen
the trailer for it i'm excited it's good
yeah i watched it about the immigration
crisis people being lied to and all that
stuff
i think the immigration thing is just
it's very complex i think it's a major
sign this country is just eroded
what's the solution then luke well you
know personal responsibility uh not
participating in the system creating
your own systems creating your own
communities being there for your
families and being an example for
everyone about how to live your life
being not affected by the soy
and by the gmos and monsantos and and
all the other things that are chemically
castrating the future of this country uh
we've been bombarded we've been attacked
i think health is one of the major
aspects that that we should be talking
about more because
essentially you know when you look at
fifth or fourth generational warfare
depends on how you see it the first
thing you have to do is to destroy the
human being and one of the easiest way
to do that is through of course
poisoning that person and i think a lot
of our food is poison i think we need to
really
start to understand nutrition and the
importance of of working out sleeping
right getting rid of stress and more
importantly eating right because almost
everywhere you look right now in our
mainline society something is trying to
hurt you for the benefit of someone else
and i think with food it's being done in
such a huge way and we could get into
the debates about seed oils vegetable
oils sugar
gmos
and all these artificial things that are
just added that have been wreaking havoc
and once people are you know unhealthy
physically this leads to people being
unhealthy mentally and there's a big
correlation between the gut and the mind
and i think that correlation um is being
taken advantage of by a lot of powerful
people who are purposefully trying to
get rid of your health who are trying to
attack your gut and trying to of course
make you absolutely mentally unstable
and i think a lot of people are mentally
unstable because of the diets that we're
given and told to eat every single day i
think that's very much true and another
aspect of it even aside from the
nutritional elements which i would agree
with you there are some serious concerns
there is to habituate people towards
choosing foods which have a pleasant
taste but no real substance to them
because that habituates a person towards
making decisions based on what is the
most convenient for them and the most
pleasurable and always looking for the
path of least resistance rather than
doing what is actually in alignment with
reality it's drugs they're literally
drugging us through our food supply and
at the same time chemically castrating
us so we can't even reproduce that's the
the basic uh you know byline that i
think is the most important thing to to
talk about most important thing to
promote and you could be an example of
not being affected by it by of course
living your best life being healthy
choosing to eat the right foods choosing
to to actually look into nutrition look
into things like uh organs liver and get
away from all the other nonsense out
there that absolutely is destroying your
mental physical and spiritual health
there's fluoride in our water yes yes
there is involuntarily
what are you talking about i caught
shame i caught sheamus drinking fluoride
and i'm like sheamus it was straight
fluoride i ordered it from my dentist i
was like yeah let me just do some shots
just no that's
very bad for you yes that will you will
die is it well that actually kill i was
just i was making fun of luke because
i've never had fluoride but look
what you're saying so i think another
issue too with this generation is we
have a generation of parents that have
been convinced through big pharma that
if you have a boy or girl and you know
she has a little bit too much energy
just put him on pills exactly on pills
no no no they give him a doctor
the doctor tried to do that with my mom
i'm glad that my mom's old-school
salvador and she was like i'm gonna just
give the k this kid the [ __ ]
chocolate you know
all the diets have so much sugar in them
and they're like oh these kids can't sit
at the desk for eight hours give them
riddles yeah give them frozen it's not
even just sugar it's not even just the
sugar children are not just supposed to
be sitting like that being talked about
all day so there's this massive
breakdown and i talked about this on the
show the other day but matt walsh has
this fantastic film what is a woman but
they're and i think that's wonderful but
there are also so many other definitions
that we no longer agree upon we don't
have any conception of what a child is
if you think it's normal for a kid to be
able to sit in a desk like that for
hours and hours a day you like
fundamentally do not understand children
at all well they want good factory
workers yeah that's where it comes from
the baby
the babylon bee came out with a good
article that i just have to share and
they wrote an article that's titled
marlborough adds puberty blockers to
cigarettes to make them legal for kids
and uh we're not that far away from that
kind of reality of course their
satirical website but but you know the
point is kind of driven home here about
the insanity of the future of this
country that it's being absolutely uh
destroyed from within let's go to super
chat
big time let's go super chat if you
haven't already smash that like button
would you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends and would you kindly
become a member at timcast.com to help
support our work we're gonna have a
members only show coming up for you at
11 pm on the website and it's not family
friendly so uh this tim cast after hours
all right let's see we got here in the
in the super chats
all right unashamed truth says checked
mortgage calculator it says interest
rate is at 6.9 percent wasn't it like 20
in the 80s or something
yeah it was it was extremely heimer this
is a story my parents used to tell when
they bought their first house it was a
14 interest rate and they thought that
was a steal
wow
that's crazy
grofty says buck buck lol
thank you grofty for the chicken themed
super chats that is of course a chicken
city reference eternally
all right
a magic monkey says damn it tim i woke
up this morning and couldn't turn my
head left because i pulled something
stop using your super liminal jedi mind
tricks on me oh this is brutal tonight
man i am fighting through it
it's brutal my back is killing me i
didn't work this morning yesterday
morning but i think tomorrow should be
good but it's just been bad
yeah i didn't do anything interesting i
just slept
you get old you get injured sleeping
that's how it works
soleil cucumber lime says releasing oil
from the strategic reserve is
effectively a massive 200 million dollar
barrel short position and it will get
squeezed it's another manufactured
crisis
interesting
all right
i'm not your buddy guy says it'd be nice
to live as a hobbit in the shire
peacefully living off the land and
ignoring the outside world but unless we
march to the heart of evil when willing
to confront it not even the shire can be
saved from the great evil marching ever
outward that's right true you gotta go
to the heart of mount doom
oh what does it say bub savvy says hey
tim love the show i can't wait until
mankind breaks out of its left right
paradigm and collectively realize that
it should be the people versus the state
like the world used to deal with social
and cultural issues
well interesting
chris larson says sheamus should make a
cartoon of the clintons instead of the
normal conspiracy around them they are
being followed by a serial killer that
keeps taking out their friends but
nobody believes that
it's a right-wing radical that's
hilarious that's a good one actually
that's a good one all right dtqc says
with 50 million barrels from 200 days
ago that's about 0.5 barrels per day as
of today there are 500 million barrels
in the strategic petroleum reserve that
means 1 000 days before it is depleted
at this rate just short three months of
the next presidential election
ooh interesting
so what does that mean that's bad for
them though
yeah
gamer max is praying for you tim two
days and no news vids hope you're
feeling okay uh i just taken it easy so
that we could i could at least do this
show but sitting here
painful i got a lidocaine patch and some
naproxen and it is it was a terrible
muscle strain
cole says my gas tank takes 150 to fill
up my portfolio was destroyed my dog
jasmine passed at 16 years this morning
i'm just a regular guy at my limit fj at
my limit fjb
that's how millions are feeling right
now too rough you know
and good people who didn't vote for joe
biden feeling that pain yes you know
let's say tiki good tiki god studios
says inversion table carnivore diet and
hamstring stretching i've got a bulging
disc and that combo has made me
pain-free for four straight months now
we do have an inversion table i use it
it's fantastic i'm not on a carnivore
diet but i mostly cut up the sugars do a
lot of meat and uh i don't stretch
enough that's a fact
giga db says for old man tim's walker
fund i'll be skating in a few days for
fun yeah let's get a mobility scooter
just don't use golf on me yeah exactly
john take says marx was right we have
achieved a classless society as in the
citizens of this country have no class
haha
funny joke indeed we do not
andre andre says tim get your elbow off
the table if you want to get your back
better i noticed that if you noticed for
like the past few days i haven't had my
elbows on the table oh i was like i'm
not going to do that because i mean i
try and just sit straight
what do i do with my hands just keep
them down
colby brown says libertarian luke
complain about republicans doing nothing
but when they do they do but when they
do they say how they hate
authoritarianism mfa it's your fault
they do nothing we need more
authoritarianism on the right who are
you calling an i
i do not think we need more
authoritarianism on the right i think we
need
libertarianism i think we need the
republicans to be like we're gonna
repeal these gun laws and give you back
your liberties yeah stop trying to
create more laws let's get rid of the
bad laws let's get rid of the bad
institutions the bad government agencies
that are putting in bureaucracy and
wasting people's time and money so so
yeah on that end the republicans promise
limited government but all they keep
doing is giving us more government
that's a problem that's right
francis cases tim regular gas was out at
a rural gas station and limited to 35
dollars at a suburban rural one in ohio
whoa
i don't want to look at that i know
in rural uh north northern california
hit like nine bucks it was crazy yeah no
and um um it wasn't mendocino yeah
mendocino county it was like 960 or
something
or more
i was just up there and the thing is you
won't see a gas station for
miles but not even to the next county
sometimes so uh yeah those rural parts
of the country are going to get real
real impacted by the gas what about
tesla chargers
yeah oh yeah uh yeah i forgot just just
buy a tesla solution gunfather precision
says red flag laws are nothing more than
a vehicle to introduce precedent that
will destroy due process do you guys see
that politifact where it's like
ignore
rumors that red flag laws don't uh
bypass due process and that an ex-spouse
can file a red flag if they have a
grudge literally happening
but i'm just like all right imagine what
they're claiming is true
an ex-spouse calls the police and says
you know my my significant other is
violent and dangerous run a red flag and
then go we can't do that that's fake
news
what if the woman's actually a victim
like what if there's a wife whose
husband was beating her and so she calls
and says take his guns away he's beating
me he's going to kill me and the cops go
nah nah you're just a white wife with a
grudge sorry we're not doing that or
what if you have a woman whose husband
is beating her or is you know being
attacked or threatened by some other man
and she wants to get a gun to protect
herself so he goes to the authorities
and says you know i'm really worried
about this woman here's some like
fabricated evidence i can show you to
show she's dangerous and then her guns
get taken she can't defend herself red
flag laws are stop and frisk on steroids
they're gonna kick doors in on people
who don't even have guns someone's gonna
be like this family has a gun gonna go
okay and they're gonna go in
and they're like it's got due process
people need to present evidence to the
court and it's like is it adversarial do
i get a summons and then go to court and
say it's not true your honor and more
importantly why should i have to justify
owning property why should i have to be
called into court to justify why i own
property
and so there is uh they're going to make
this argument they've they've always
made i think aaron mckinter posted this
the other day had
an article on substance i didn't read
yet but he tweeted about it basically
saying what the left generally does when
they have control over these systems is
they will create a set of rules that
they claim is going to be impartial or
will be impartially applied then they
basically stack the system with people
who lean the same way they do and will
always decide
uh against the claim of the right
leaning person whenever there is sort of
an edge case and so i mean we see this
with twitter right twitter's
twitter's actually
their codified rules have an explicit
anti-conservative bias but every single
time you bring this up to left-wing
people or even the folks at twitter
they'll say well no there's no bias
conservatives just break the rules more
often
and that's exactly what's going to
happen with red flags exactly
all right
late night hvac says as james lindsay
says we are living in herbert marcuse
world he wrote the left must always be
tolerated every violence and the right
and the right speech must always be shut
down we are living in marcuse world
oh there you go
that's what it says right there as james
lindsey says hey there you go
iggy the incubus says regarding the blm
riots of 2020 the big question is how do
we peacefully counter literal
state-sponsored terror it leaves me
speechless controlling words controlling
minds by michael knowles why would you
do that just selling more books for
michael north he's the last guy you want
to sell more books he's gonna he's gonna
come out and be like stop please i've
sold too many books too much money i
have too much money and how much money
please let me be
all right all right
the
kltanker says i watch on spotify
normally episode 549 has been chopped up
and it skips and repeats itself around
50 44 47 26 51
416. was there editing in that
nope never edit weird it's jumping
around strangely that's odd yeah
yeah we just upload them yeah
all right
grafty says buck buck that is it that's
actually true
very true
noah zork says tim name your new
clothing clothing line credible threads
incredible threads
that's a good band name
all right
jean shirt says don't let aggressive
emotional control freaks take your
ability to self-preservation in an
imperfect world equitable defense means
the weak need guns
that's right true equity we have to make
sure everybody has guns everybody should
have
a gun that's as powerful as the person
with the most powerful if it has you
know what i mean so if one guy has a 50
bmg you know crew served everyone has to
have one that's equity
that is equity i just want to be with a
bazooka like someone just introduced me
as a boom that's right yeah all right
it's wrath of paul says things are going
to get spicy as we get closer to the
midterms
desperate dems will do anything to stay
in power
any crisis will be exploited to try to
win votes or maybe even postpone the
election we're already seeing that with
the u of all day shooting we've been
trying to report on it the texas
democrats are raising millions upon
millions off that shooting and a lot of
money is coming from washington dc that
a coincidence showed up less than 24
hours to go put his finger in governor
greg abbott's face literally
politicizing the dead children that's
like they're tackling
savvy j says wishing the greatest
president ever a very happy birthday
enjoy your special day president trump
that's right i think i thought that they
were talking about uh kim jong-un no no
no it is also flag day which i've always
said very funny
strange ben hickson says reish al ghul
and the league of shadow in league of
shadows have infiltrated everything to
burn it all down i think the left
politicians do what in do what in the
moment gives them the most power and
money aka the short-sighted i agree i
agree
all right
ultra maga says i'm in socal got my
mind's event ticket for june 25th also
looking forward to your guests tomorrow
i won't spoil it and say who they are
get better tim well i mean prager
already tweeted it out so yeah
yeah prager's dennis prager that's right
tweeted out he'd be on the show tomorrow
i'm stoked and i was like oh cool he
made a video and he's like i'm dennis
prager i'll be on tim cass i'm going to
be on tim
and i was like oh that's cool he is i
was like oh he's coming on i'm like
sitting in bed
no we knew he was going
all right stan t stan 2 says please ask
jorge about the soros-backed fund taking
over 18 prominent hispanic radio
stations making sure it's hard leftist
ideology yeah we talked a little bit
about that yeah yeah we did in um a lot
of my friends work in spanish
conservative media and that's something
that they're trying to keep an eye on
but like i said i actually think if you
guys are looking at that it's a good
sign that means that they're losing the
hispanic vote like i said turn on
univision telemundo right now you think
you're watching fox news so the
hispanics shout out to them 26 baby well
you know it's it's no wonder because
they're trying to take this really like
niche religion for upper-class white
people and force it onto every minority
community that's basically what like the
far left will politically tell you crt
all that transgender stuff is a gift
gift that turns off hispanic voters
quicker than time anything
all right
what to say asym solutions tim your
comment about only one side being
punished is discussed as a major factor
in rebellions by both cambridge
university and army war college studies
and revolutions in the cold war they are
doing this on purpose
well we'll see i suppose
all right what we got
depiromantic oh i see says
you should consider getting translations
on your website so that you can reach
spanish-speaking people
put all the articles in spanish
joe biden noes buenos
[Music]
[Laughter]
john shaw says tim why have there been
so many food plants in the us that have
burned down this year also these times
are reminding me of jimmy carter's
presidency into reagan biden as carter
desantis says the new reagan cold war
with china
um i don't know if more food plants have
burned down than normal because people
are paying attention to it yeah yeah i i
will say because i've been doing some
reporting in california um the farmers
that have been interviewing california
are very worried because the state of
california is already restricting their
water um so they're already telling me
that they think that we'll see some food
shortages pretty soon so scary stuff
hey some solution says everyone should
read no other way out by john goodwin
and the political context behind
successful revolutionary movements the
case studies by the dod
very interesting
swagger says hey tim any thoughts on
starting a segment highlighting
defensive use of firearm stories i feel
like 2a could use some positive coverage
mother defends family from invaders yeah
i mean there's always opportunities with
stories like that we're we're uh trying
to launch a brand channel
which would be a youtube channel just
for the website so we'd have a whole
variety of content and we could probably
do a series on that we should get to the
point where we can get it up and running
requires hiring people and that requires
money and we're going into a recession
and so you know
things might not be going so well but i
think we'll be alright we'll see what
happens if you all sign up as members
we'll continue to do our work that's
right d-pad says who would lead the
people in a revolution or equivalent
event
how would the people know what the plan
is without organization the people will
get trampled uh i posted a meme about
this oh yeah on instagram oh that's
right you can go to instagram.comcast
and get your answer because it was the
last thing i posted who will lead well i
posted that meme
tim cast on instagram and you'll see go
find out yeah and then you'll laugh
all right
ball sacks says that's right ball sacks
they are not taking away our rights
humans cannot take away god-given rights
y'all should have the guys from the 10th
amendment center on no they can infringe
upon them we should have them
infringe upon them
bug hq says right out the gate with our
bug bugs and pod slogan ask yourself
where will you get your bugs bug hq has
got you covered pods coming soon no it's
true i mean look if the government
starts feeding us bugs they're going to
have a bug shortage in like three months
right obviously there's gonna be bug
inflation we should we should uh legit
contract someone to make us a pod with
like a cricket dispenser in it oh my
gosh as like a gag yeah that'd be
awesome
that's where luke will stay and then you
sleep with the chickens okay
stuff
i
and there's nothing wrong with that yeah
it's fine get up with the chickens
they warn me when there are enemies
coming that's right yeah
raymond g stanley jr says i'm in a civil
war with my toilet after taco tuesday
what are you that's my type of guy right
there taco bell that's my type of gun
that's a civil right to go to nightly
actually
cultural appropriate okay smells like up
dog in here says have you guys seen the
florida 13
have you guys seen the florida 13th
congressional gp primary one candidate
wanted to murder anna paulina luna and
talked about putting a hit out on her
and now his defense attorney is running
in his place you have to have anna
paulina luna on the on to talk about it
it's nuts that was a crazy story i
actually even made mainstream media like
political actually report on it and uh
it actually helped diana plenty she's
been fundraising like crazy and she
looks like she might win her seat good
for her
all right john shaw says there is a
market among uh among us young people
i'm 22 for authenticity we will
literally vote for logan paul before we
vote for an establishment fool on either
side i totally hear that yeah i'm on
that train too yep that's how trump got
in
matt says even though y'all rip on luke
all the time i met him back in my ron
paul days and i'm so happy he uh he
he his back on the show he's back love
seeing principled people remain so hey
real quick tim uh we gotta mention this
honorable mention savannah hernandez was
banned today that's right off of twitter
for her third time i think just for
being a reporter
um so everyone if you guys can go follow
her on her truth social that's at sav
says and her youtube channel obviously
savannah hernandez so we just want to
support people that get banned
and get silenced so
thanks for taking away my moment there
yeah we love savannah hernandez uh
vermin supreme also got taken down yeah
a couple days ago which is absolutely i
i went to the rainbow gathering with him
awesome dude and but what what does he
say that's like bannable well he's like
you know he he likes comedy and humor
and yeah that's outlawed now yeah well
and the thing is savannah actually got
banned just for interviewing people at
pride here in dc and she asked him like
you know what do you identify as and
people were like oh i don't even know so
just for her posting other people's
answers
one of the posts one of savannah's posts
um was those interviews it was almost at
a million views and in the caption it
said
pray for this generation
so it's like what a horrible thing to
say a horrible thing to say
let's read this one from for uh farrell
one third of the maryland legislature
was arrested in 1861 because of
secession however the body was refusing
to finance the war and openly declared
lincoln a tyrant pro-war candidates then
swept new election wow whoa
get a little history lesson there
things are going to get crazy
igloo wi-fi says hey tim i love the show
and i agree that younger people are fed
up that's why i filed with the fec
for the house in texas 25th putting up a
platform and grass rooting my campaign
keep on doing good
excuse me
not my backgrounds and i got hiccups
all right
let's see we got raymond g stanley jr
says riot squad in the house keep it the
good work
yeah right baby
all right
illumine says tim you should get
billboard in the
rhino gun grabbers districts to let
people know what they're voting for
we could do that too
we could do that too
all right
deutero76 says biden is forming a credit
reporting system under the cfpb
this would give the government all the
info that goes into your credit score
sounds like the beginning of a social
credit system oh let them have it let
them have it your social credit system
i mean i think they're already what's
supine in our in our bank accounts if we
have more than like 600 bucks yeah but i
was told by fact checkers they wouldn't
do anything bad with that so oh you're
right you're right oh that's right thank
you thank you thank you
yes the fact checkers know what's best
for us
the ministry of truth amen yes amen
charles says a random brainwashed dude
up here in quebec 170 million dollars
the lottery ticket and swore to give
seven million dollars to ukraine in the
news
two prop uh yeah
he should give the 70 and keep the seven
we should just we should just rename our
country to ukraine that's what we should
do yeah and we should be based what a
base take i love it that's baseball
i'm gonna do well in this regime you're
gonna be great yeah yeah dude i got
great ideas ricky thank you ricky
alhendrick says had an idea to include
tim cast article headline and subtitle
with your time square billboard people
would be curious to see what the article
says you can't there's laws uh there's
strict rules on what you can and can't
advertise so overtly political things
you can't do and then i
how would they find the article is the
challenge right it's like go to
timcast.com it's too much to read you
only get 10 seconds so
most most billboards everywhere will
will not approve ads that have certain
words like many won't take the word
politics
just about right and we ours our
billboard says culture news politics so
this one approved us
yup surprising
tim my friend says for the idea that we
will come together when authoritarianism
comes knocking remember that people in
gulag still believed they would be
absolved gulag archipelago alexander
sultanate yeah yeah everyone thinks like
they'll like this is what everyone does
they're like well when the mob comes
down the street i'll just keep my head
down and they won't come to my house and
then they do well this is exactly why
family members would sell out other
family members because they're like i
can get in good with the bosses it'll be
fine as you just saw out a few more
people one in five people were
informants well lydia we actually we saw
a little bit of that with january 6 we
saw family members turning their own
family members in like it takes so
little very little thomas cullnan says
did you know that disco records sales
were up 400 percent for the year ending
1976. if these trends continue hey
disco stew
it's a good super chat but when that
joke was made it was like 1996. you know
so now it's
an even crazier joke
all right gary langley also mentions the
gulag archipelago is it archipa
archipelago archipelago i'm always
[Music]
there were still true believer
communists in the gulags there was no
turning back for some pray for them
that's right
there will be
cody lillico says my town is recently
found uh found out a bill gates related
entity bought 13 million crops and the
town is making a chinese wet corn mill
in our city limits and it's across from
the grand forks air force base oh it's
really nice
all right takakes says tim been
listening for a few years retired combat
medic every gun law except the second
amendment is illegal the only way
they'll ever get my guns from me is from
my cold dead hands
you know what what if there was a law
because we had michael mouse and he was
like all gun laws are unconstitutional
and i was like what if they passed a law
saying they have to give you a gun then
there would be a gun shortage in like
two weeks if the federal government was
in charge of providing people with guns
they would just completely destroy the
gun supply and maybe distribute anything
exactly they literally cannot do
anything flo says 15 a gallon after
november if democrats win a
congressional super majority knowing how
they always get their way though it'll
probably get to 20 by this time next
year regardless
republicans are going to come out and
they're going to be like we've
compromised with democrats to raise gas
only to 16 a gallon
10 principled republicans sell out their
districts
what's that one like clip of biden like
saying you need a little breathing room
you need a little breathing room my dad
used to say we got to give the people a
little breathing little little breath
you guys could youtube it's the weirdest
he says it like oh like throughout the
years
all right it reminds me of that it's
like it'll be at twenty dollars but give
him a little breathing room with sixteen
dollars
zen main says the red wave is coming
all thanks to the tampon shortage
well you know when i've been hearing the
red wave is coming for 30 years but when
women see that there's a shortage
they're going to vote republican so
certainly that'll make the red wave you
know even bigger why what did you think
he meant i don't know that's voting
republican of course right
these women are mostly democrats they're
going to be like i gotta vote republican
because it's a shortage yeah yeah yeah
red wave that's right red wave
all right avb 19d says what's going on
crew luke who's the best nba duo ever
obviously stockton malone right also tim
has tim been a stretch therapist for
four years need to hire me to make sure
you can keep skating
i i got i got hurt by sleeping like i
didn't even skate the day before it's
like we were just like hanging out and
we went and like played pool and then i
went to bed and woke up and i'm like i
can't move
because it was like cold in the room or
something stupid like with the ac on
full blast who do you think is the best
duo oh it's kobe and shaq come on this
is
l.a lakers yeah you didn't know that
literally yeah
look you're a little biased
[Laughter]
over jordan and pippen oh yeah yeah baby
really all right let's little littles
pressure washes hey tim any
recommendations for a good survival
download app we got the idea from you
buddy us the goats and the chickens send
our support and thanks
what's a good survival at blue let me
see what i got on my phone well there's
a number of people coming together and
bringing forward videos and documents
teaching people how to
homestead how to have their own farms um
i don't know an exact one off of that i
just have one called survival manual but
there's a bunch of stuff that you should
definitely download and have as a
physical copy um just in case just in
case you lose connection or there's
energy outages you should have something
in physical form that you can look at
that will teach you basic
medical procedures uh basic ways to grow
your own food and raise your own
livestock
so i have this app it's just called
survival manual yeah it's amazing yeah i
tell them i tell people to download my
videos on my survival apocalypse
training courses
uh and they they could very easily do
that and have a copy yo but but this app
is really amazing it's got it's
psychology power planning kits apps
medicine shelter water fire food plants
poisonous plants animals tools desert
tropical cold sea water crossing how to
find your directions man-made hazards
this is amazing we go through very
similar things in my program as well
well sure sure i'm also saying download
the app absolutely download the app
download the information and have it on
a physical copy because there might be a
time where you can't go online yeah no
power yep you'll have your phone you'll
be if only i could turn it on i don't
know if i could eat this berry or not
then you die it's like what was it the
into the wild guy had like it had like a
seed and had like stripes and he read
the book and thought it was edible but
he got sick and then died no no
yeah you know you know i they i i was
reading how to survive and it said you
can eat leaves what you do is the first
thing you do is you take the leaf and
rub it on your skin then you wait 5-10
minutes yeah then you rip the leaf open
rub it on your skin with the exposed
side wait five ten minutes nothing
happens then you bite a small piece and
chew on it and wait five ten minutes if
nothing happens then you eat the leaf
then you wait five ten more minutes if
nothing happens eat some leaves i'm not
saying you should do that i'm saying
look it up i was watching a video on it
yeah cause i watched a deer eating
leaves in the yard and i was like can we
eat those do they taste good because i
eat spinach yes you know that's true
put caesar dressing on it yeah that's
great some
you will eat the plants yeah oh yeah
we're gonna make we're gonna make fried
dandelion dandelions apparently are like
a normal thing to eat in appalachia so
like the pilgrims brought it over
because it was medicinal and now it's
like a weed everywhere but apparently it
tastes good it tastes like mushrooms you
take the the top of the flowering part
when it's yellow and you fry it you eat
it no joke yeah i might try that yeah i
had food
i bought some dandelion tea legit the
best you've ever had i was i was
surprised
ian talks about dandelion tea and i was
like what they're weeds and he's like no
they're good
and then i was like okay so i bought
some and seriously it's so it's so good
i had some it's pretty good yeah that's
amazing
all right
david toronto says bernie is and was a
scammer things would be worse biden told
us what he was going to do y'all fell
for his bs
i think i mean
i don't know how much worse you can get
right now i know yeah
wait just wait
it's coming what do we got here
rod undefined rod says we can't eat bugs
we already have a bug shortage of the
lack of pollinators that's right i don't
know you just take a piece of wood you
put it on the ground and you pick it up
the next day and there's bugs you eat
them it's like lion king yeah you know
you shouldn't eat bugs
uh the main issue is like you need to
like grow like if you're gonna eat bugs
you've got to grow them like if you want
to go out in the middle of the woods
just eat random stuff i guess i mean i
wouldn't recommend it
all right misanthropic says love your
work dude wish we had something like
this in australia ever thought of going
international i would not know how to do
that
yeah you you need someone who knows
australia
it's not me have someone translate your
articles into australia that's a good
point
yes
oh joe biden's no good huh it's gonna be
it's gonna be a civil war
all right we'll grab one more here
elliott says best book i have is called
back to basics everything from building
cabins to sustainable farming to useful
household crafts amazing my friends
if you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to the
channel and share the show with your
friends head over to timcast.com we're
gonna have a members only show up for
you to be published around 11 p.m it is
not family friendly it is the after hour
show and so definitely check that out
become a member at timcast you can
follow the show at tim cast irl follow
us on instagram you can follow me
everywhere at timcast follow me on
instagram drew you want to shout
anything out yes you guys can follow my
work uh realtime reporting on twitter
drew h live getter and all that other
good stuff and watch my show monday
through friday front lines powered by
turning point usa on the turning point
usa channel
perfect and then yeah guys follow me on
twitter is jorge ventura media instagram
is jorge ventura tv we have a lot of
good coverage front lines border we're
going to be back at the border pretty
soon doing that also at the daily color
we're working on a few documentaries we
just released cartelville last year on
the drug cartels in california we're
actually working and editing it's
already shot on a new documentary up in
northern california we kind of followed
drug cartels up there and they're more
asian and dominated so i think you guys
will find that fascinating but yeah
we're breaking news our real time
always on the ground so i think you guys
will like it so uh bien trabajar mia mi
hormanos
my survival class is up on luke
uncensored.com i speak a lot about
nutrition gut health bettering yourself
it's not a spanish class
is it in spanish we're doing a giveaway
today and we got a forum
uncensored
okay
that's where i go around i literally go
around acapulco screaming
and uh i have a lot of fun in acapulco
but yeah separate story
my name is seamus goglin uh i have a
youtube channel called freedom tunes
we create cartoons uh every we release
one every single week sometimes twice a
week sometimes three times a week you
guys are about to get a bunch of
cartoons if you go over there and
subscribe we're gonna be releasing a lot
uh next week also we just launched a
website freedomtunes.com so if you want
to help support independent content
creators myself and my team and people
putting these videos together who are
trying to challenge the dominant media
culture go over there become a member
for five bucks a month you'll get extra
cartoons and you'll be helping us fight
the good fight
uh this evening did not disappoint it
never does with jorge or drew it's
always very exciting thank you guys so
much again for coming i really
appreciate it you guys can follow me on
twitter and mines.com at sourpatchletts
and all my socials including my cat are
over on sourpatchlits.me
we will see you all over at timcast.com
thanks for hanging out
you